[Rires]
prémat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui fait encore des bruits
même quand elle est finie avec nous ce
soir
l'homme politique préféré des français
bernard kouchner
[Applaudissements]
après un été de folie à saint tropez
tire pas mal
nous parlera de son aile
étasunien lio la robe avait voix et
sur grand écran marina foïs 1
son nouveau livre était jean référent
preda y bd comment l'année et qui a
vendu son âme pour le pétrole saoudien
avec votre père quand elle écrit elle a
aussi du talent si lui testud
la femme
lcdr le visage et le corps de barbie
magnifique témoignage sur l'immigration
fatou diome
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr j'en oublie
là on
[Applaudissements]
or massif alors ya pas mal de nouveautés
dans cette émission jeune hector le
petit écran que tu as sur ton bureau qui
te permettra de recevoir des sms des
téléspectateurs pendant l'émission il y
en a déjà non oui c'est quoi ce ver de
merde
évidemment les téléspectateurs
réagissent par ya aussi autre chose
laurent c'est que tu as inventé la carte
de bons clients qui sera donné dans
cette émission à des gens qui se
comportent particulièrement bien en bon
client comme quels seront les avantages
de cette carte tirer les avantages de
cette carte bon client c'est que nos
invités pourront revenir quand ils
veulent dans l'émission on vient marquer
comme ça il va être la carte et ils
rentrent à la même s'ils ont pas d'actu
même s'ils n'ont pas de promo ils
peuvent venir quand ils veulent et ils
sont reçus fêter s'extrait aurait acquis
on va la donner soir 20h hier déjà un
pierre tu m'entends bien sûr que je
tente en ce jeudi saint pierre richard -
non
on n'a pas le bon pierre en liaison
alors pierre palmade et dans le carré
viip et en compagnie de bernard kouchner
en blanc bernard est ce que vous
connaissez tous les deux non mais depuis
le temps qu'on attend on a fait
connaissance
sega mais si toi vers l'art oui bien sûr
enseigner pas régulièrement au franc ce
genre de commentaires pertinents
donc revenus provenaient quand vous
voulez mais voilà ça m'en sors tu vas
voir
évidemment on aurait pu avoir ben laden
mais il voulait venir en aide quand je
voulais avoir bertrand cantat mais il
n'a pas pu se libérer et sarkozy sarkozy
on l'a invité mais avec tout ce qui
traîne dans les loges on s'est dit on va
en prendre pour dix ans donc on l'a pas
qu'est ce qui traîne dans les loges rien
alors
alors donc on a pour commencer bernard
kouchner
[Musique]
patrick bernard comme vous savez c'est
une émission qui peut à la fois très con
est très sérieuse tout le monde en parle
et on va commencer par un truc un peu un
peu sérieux un peu grave qui c'est qui
s'est passé cet été
l'attentât contre l'onu à bagdad
d'abord c'est un symbole parce que c'est
plus seulement une attaque contre les
contre les américains mais contre le
monde entier en fait un attaquant l'onu
non c'était comme on peut dire des
comment peut-on dire des sentinelles de
la démocratie des gens qui nous
représentait d'abord cessé nous nous
tous les français comme les autres
membres des nations unies qui ont été
attaqués et c'est la démocratie qu'on a
visé est la prochaine cible
hélas je l'avais dit à l'époque mais
depuis ça s'est révélé vrai et pas
seulement parce que je l'avais dit bien
entendu mais la prochaine cible serait
avait jeudi les islamistes démocrates
les islamistes les rangs et c'est ce
qu'on a fait à nadjaf en tuant encore
plus de fidèles à la sortie de la prière
et surtout l'imam l'ayatollah baqer
hakim qui était un homme de démocratie
le thé les trois bernard que je
connaissais très bien avec qui j'avais
longuement dialogué et qui est
d'ailleurs c'était souvent coupés dans
les discours qu'on entendait de lui bien
sûr il disait il faut que les américains
un jour s'en aille au plus vite mais ce
sera en ayant établi des élections un
pluripartisme et avec pour but la
démocratie une démocratie pour les
irakiens alors disparition donc de
sergio vieira de mello nadia younès jean
selim canal mais fiona watson tous vos
amis sérgio des mélos vous l'avez
rencontrée il ya longtemps à genève en
71 quand vous êtes allés présenter
médecins sans frontières au comité la
croix-rouge et nous étions rencontrés là
et depuis nous ne sommes pas la dernière
fois vous l'avez vu c'était en 2003 à
genève et vous êtes dit éclair puisque
c'est votre façon à
vous servir on en parle beaucoup parce
que c'était la figure de proue
mais jean céline canal que j'appelais
mon fils et qui avait 30 ans qui venait
d'avoir un bébé qui a maintenant un mois
qui s'appelle mathias selim
et lorsqu'on a enterré jean selim qui
avaient la nationalité française entre
autres c'était évidemment à l'église
saint julien le pauvre très émouvant il
ya un moment donné son fils qui étaient
là qui avait trois semaines a poussé un
grand cri et ce petit garçon qui a crié
dans l'église c'était la vie qui
revenait c'était pas du tout rideuses de
souffrance ou une jérémiades c'était de
dire ça continue il faudra continuer
pour jean selim pour nadia pour sergio
pour fiona pour les autres car il y en a
eu 25 qui sont morts lors bernard
kouchner après cet attentat la moitié du
personnel de l'onu à bagdad a quitté la
ville et puis à ce moment là les
américains donnent l'impression d'avoir
besoin de l'onu mais malgré tout en
dirigeant l'onu sur place c'est à dire
ils veulent pas laisser le pouvoir à
l'onu ils veulent se faire aider par le
nu est ce que c'est possible
j'espère que c'est possible mais ce que
j'espère possible c'est une entente
entre l'onu c'est-à-dire la
représentation de la communauté
internationale et les états unis il faut
que d'un côté comme de l'autre on n'en
fasse pas un bras de fer comme au
conseil de sécurité je brandis lever tôt
parce que je suis un jeu viril il faut
que chacun fasse un pas dans la
direction du compromis alors les
américains ont cette fâcheuse habitude
mais peut-être et depuis la somalie où
on peut la comprendre
ils ont l'habitude d'être de diriger les
opérations militaires de ne pas accepter
d'autres directions et ça n'est pas vrai
au kosovo avec l'ô tan
il ya eu au contraire un premier général
qui était à général anglais puis un
allemand puis un italien puis un turc et
ça a très bien marché et si je peux me
permettre de dire très bien vrai qu'il
leur faudra combien aux américains pour
rétablir la paire niaque
j'en sais rien je souhaite que le mandat
soit élargi le mandat des nations unies
et qui est une aide de l'onu parce que
les militaires ne savent pas faire ça ne
savent pas faire la police sur tous les
résultats américains parce que les
militaires anglais je les brûle mieux
quand même - oui parce qu'ils ont eu 30
ans de guerre d'irlande pour être dans
la foulée connaît
mais c'est pas leur tâche ils savent pas
à réparer l'électricité ils ne savent
pas assurer le fonctionnement
démocratique des partis ils ne savent
pas de données la sécurité aux femmes
dans les rues alors maintenant il ya d
ali baba on appelle ça alibaba en irak
qui sèment la terreur et les américains
ne sont pas là pour réprimer ces gens
pour réprimer ses vols pour réprimer ces
viols
ils sont dans leurs casernes ils
patrouillent c'est leur méthode est donc
il faut qu'ils aient les civils il faut
que des organisations non
gouvernementales
or on a appris aujourd'hui que une
majorité d'entre elles allaient quitter
l'irak
je ne sais pas combien de temps il
faudra mais certainement plusieurs
années vous étiez favorable à
l'intervention américaine en irak
j'étais favorable au départ de saddam
hussein et mon papier le seul que j'ai
écrit dans le monde s'appelait ni saddam
ni la guerre je pense qu'on aurait
peut-être pu j'étais naïf mais je suis
toujours naïve sinon j'aurais pas
survécu et je pensais que toute la
communauté internationale pouvaient
faire pression avec évidemment le
déploiement militaire qui toute façon
était déjà en route
le déploiement militaire américain pour
que saddam son ail et qu'on évite la
guerre si on avait dû la faire au moins
lorette ont fait tous ensemble au nom
des valeurs démocratiques
1 dans tous les cas votre concept du
devoir d'ingérence on prend un mauvais
coup là parce que le résultat est
brillant quand même c'est bientôt la
guerre civile en irak civile avait lieu
avant un les assassinats de masse avait
lu avant et personne ne s'en inquiétait
je me méfie des gens qui disent
maintenant c'est le chaos alors qu'il
disait rien contre le chaos de saddam ni
à fait à ma maman je vous le dis non pas
cinq cent mille morts seulement mais
apparemment des millions alors vous
étiez représentant de l'onu au kosovo
pendant deux ans est-ce que vous iriez à
bagdad remplacer sergio des mélos
personne ne me le demande rhin
contrairement à ce qu'on dit dans la
presse et personne ne me parle moi j'ai
parlé à kofi annan bien sûr mais si on
me le demandait je le ferai sans doute
ça dépend de conditions du mandat si
c'est pour ne rien pouvoir faire et être
caché et protégé non je freine bas toute
façon personne ne me le demande c'est
une réaction
mes amis sont morts si je n'y allais pas
ouais je ne serai plus rien mes propres
aux yeux d'ailleurs mais personne ne le
demande bien
alors bernard kouchner en revanche en
france
ça marche très fort si ça marche pas
trop à l'onu vous êtes l'homme politique
préféré des français selon un sondage
ipsos le point
lorsque la 64e maintenant ah bon le
sondage qui vient de tomber et c'est
françois bayrou alors ça ça va lui faire
une surprise alors c'était quand même
bien sûr il faut que je leur ai glace et
non mais c'est bon mais c'est branché
directement vers l'udf c'est pour ça il
était à 64 % et pendant l'été vous êtes
passé à 67 % c'est un véritable
agriculteurs sur les conditions
atmosphériques sûrement et puis
deuxièmement c'est peut-être que ce que
je dis pas complète proco j'en sais rien
aux américains les français apprécient
non sa vie sinon 67% c'est énorme ça
sert à rien non ça c'est gentil de me le
dire oui le problème c'est que doit être
président de la république il faut avoir
une base partisane et vous vous êtes
plutôt à un électron libre au ps fait
pas 67% de partisans un bon si jamais
vous savez le ps est un appareil
extrêmement inventif et réactif on sait
jamais ça peut venir
pierre palmade tu m'entends est ce que
tu deviens pierre écoute moi je trouve
que ça démarre sur les chapeaux de roue
oui de la musique de l'humour c'est tout
ce qu'il fallait pour partir pierre est
ce que tu veux très ce que tu voterais
pour bernard kouchner présent la
république mais j'adore
lemay mais qu'est ce que tu m'emmerdes
avec ces questions n'est
j'y comprends rien à la politique
apparaît la fadeur le métier j'adore le
le médecin s'allonge toi lapierre vient
donc au ps fait pas 67 % quand même
bernard kouchner là je ne pense pareil
hélas il ya hollande qui vous cherche
avec un fusil à pompe êtes au courant
quand même du tout saccagé vous êtes son
cauchemar qu'est ce que vous ne savez
pas qui va arriver là le cauchemar est
ce que vous croyez une seconde que si
ces marques est ce que c'est vrai quand
même sur que non c'est pas vrai mais
c'est marqué à sagem mieux hein c'est
pas marqué c'est vrai alors qu'en
hollande dit je veux entendre le ps
parlé d'une seule voix vous dites oui si
c'est la mienne non jeudi la raison mais
c'est pas demain la veille
ouais bien alors en tous les cas non
c'est vrai qu'avec avec au long de sa
barre de la cellule dans sa partie nord
attendait bernard ça a commencé avec les
retraites
vous avez dit que vous étiez d'accord
avec le d'accord j'ai dit que quand on
avait cherché pendant cinq ans 1 m 10
ans puisque ça a commencé sous le
gouvernement raffarin a réformé les
retraites on n'avait pas se plaindre
quand ça se faisait il avait mis à le
faire nous mêmes un nom alain donc j'ai
dit quelque chose d'essentiel et en même
temps de dérisoire que tout le monde
connaît je n'ai pas dit que j'étais
partisan comme il l'était du projet de
monsieur raffarin
mais réformer les retraites était une
nécessité parce qu'être moins en moins
de gens qui travaillent le plus en plus
à la retraite alors elle a baissé
bon ben voilà d'accord mais on aurait pu
faire mieux si ce camp maintenant on
aurait pu le faire mieux surtout si nous
l'avions fait nous-mêmes et d'ailleurs
dans le programme de jospin s'il avait
été élu
et bien il y aurait eu la réforme il y
avait deux comme proposition la réforme
alors y'a filles ont déjà fait un petit
peu d'accord avec lui s'énerve les
socialistes bové vous dites que c'est du
populisme du poujadisme de la démagogie
ce qui énerve aussi évidemment les gens
de gauche je dis que les réponses sont
souvent démagogique mais que les
questions la manière de s'indigner et de
vouloir changer le monde mais non
seulement familière mais très
sympathique simplement quand on voit son
attaque contre l'organisation mondiale
du commerce est convoité hier il ya eu
un succès formidable grâce à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
parce qu'on va avoir des génériques pour
combattre le sida lé entièrement jeudi
s'est trompé mais ça n'empêche pas de
trouver non seulement sympathique quand
ils posent ces questions quand il dit à
mon avis des choses tout à fait anti
scientifiques sur les ogm qui sont là
aussi une part de notre avenir
on peut se méfier il faut faire
attention c'est le syndrome de
précaution tout ce qu'on veut d'accord
mais les ogm c'est un peu comme
l'insuline qu'on a fait à part
maintenant l'insuline
à partir de là des modifications
génétiques et avant n'en avaient pas
assez donc faut pas dire toujours
n'importe quoi mr mais il a des réponses
formidable à d'autres questions et bien
la canicule vous avez fait fort d'abord
vous dit le gouvernement peut pas
changer la température la chaleur c'est
pas la faute du gouvernement donc c'est
vrai bon assez vite
jouons pas aux fanfarons aurais-je fait
mieux oui parce que j'ai vraiment
m'attendais c'est vrai que j'aurais
peut-être pas fait mieux
mais en même temps quand on est dans
l'opposition dire en parlant du
gouvernement qui est en place
aurais-je fait mieux ça être pas
l'opposition à laquelle on appartient
oui d'accord mais mon raisonnement c'est
pas l'opposition quand il s'agit de
santé publique c'est pas opposition
majorité c'est d'essayer de faire la
vérité est d'essayer d'améliorer si ça
se reproduisait notre système allemand
alors attendez il n'y avait rien de
prévu c'est à dire que nous n'avions pas
la fin nous n'avions pas moi je suis pas
responsable
je suis pas ministre il y en avait un il
y avait direction générale de la santé
il y avait des agences personne n'a
prévenu pourquoi parce que nous ne
suivons pas les courbes de température
dans la santé publique on suit les
courbes de température quand ça se
traduit par des maladies et l'hiver
quand il fait froid on suit les
pneumonies les grippes et ce n'est pas
là je parle pas de ça
là rien n'était prévu et donc avait pas
d'indicateur sans doute vous n'auriez
pas mieux réagi mais le fait de le dire
quand on est dans l'opposition
le fait de dire j'aurais pas fait mieux
c'est pas sympa ce que vous me demandez
de mentir parce qu'on est dans
l'opposition
moi je ne fais pas mais j'ai dit aussi
que j'aurais agi différemment
j'ai dit aussi qu'il y avait une
responsabilité j'ai dit que sans doute
des réactions avait été lente et j'ai
dit très clairement que c'était un
problème social que c'était monsieur
fillon et que en effet le gouvernement
avait coupé les crédits des personnes
chargées que ça c'était là la seule
chose que vous avez
reprocher finalement au gouvernement
vous dites mattei aurait dû à la
télévision pour dire faut faire boire
les vieux surtout allait s'inquiéter
dans les maisons et partout du sort des
personnes âgées
c'est ça qu'il aurait fallu faire car il
était trop tard cette crise humanitaire
devait se traduire par une réaction
humanitaire c'est à dire social
collectif de la france et je pense qu'il
aurait fallu au moment où on l'a
découvert allez demander de s'intéresser
dans son imaginaire dans une bonne idée
vous avez qu'il était venu à la télé on
n'est pas un problème médical boire les
vieux c'est sûr que ceux-ci d'accord
voilà on vous a quand même un petit peu
senti cet été pas très loin du du
gouvernement raffarin et on se demande
finalement si vous n'avez pas des
accointances et que ce gouvernement
raffarin
on dit que que jean pierre raffarin vous
demande votre avis dans les périodes
difficiles est ce que c'est
alors il les écoute pas non c'est non
c'est pas vraiment enfin écoutez j'ai vu
des trucs ce temps la presse
d'aujourd'hui incroyable dans les
gardiens ici
oui dans l'express on dit dans les
indiscrets de l'express on dit que
jacques chirac me donne envisage de
créer un ministère des crises et vous
êtes pressenti pour être ministre je l'
ai appris tout à l'heure dans le petit
salon où avec pierre palmade nous
allongeons sur les divans ce qui se
passe dans ce petit salon danse et
attendez je croyais que ce que vous
lisez non banon sinon je me serais
suicidé depuis longtemps kouchner
président qu'au président bah ils sont
tous là non alors on dit quand même
kouchner c'est brice lalonde
c'est méchant ce concours qui seriez
prêt est ce que vous seriez prêt à
participer au gouvernement à dijon par
raffarin sauf en cas de danger nationale
bien sûr une union sacrée vous êtes
disponible à brice lalonde s'est quand
même danger nationale a commencé à
manger nationale brioude
plus sérieusement je viendrai à 10 on
peut pas être à la fois pour les indiens
et pour les cowboys tiens et ben voilà
qu'il mène loin
ouais voilà qui est une pensée politique
que j'apprécie autant c'est bien ça
résume un tout petit peu tous les
problèmes métaphysiques dont nous avons
à comprendre l'importance les indiens et
cow-boys mavuba c'est une philosophie
qui ne me convient pas bien
est-ce que
est ce que vous êtes toujours socialiste
oui comme tony blair ou comme ou pas il
faut prendre 2 le monde a beaucoup
changé je crois que le 11 septembre a
changé encore plus
je pense que la mondialisation ne peut
pas être un problème
rejetée comme forcément hostile et
dommageable et qu'il faut avec l'om c
est le sida par exemple on vient de le
voir apporter une globalisation positive
j'aime bien le mot social mondialisme
par exemple bien sûr je suis socialiste
est ce que vous êtes pour la baisse des
impôts de 3 % écoutez je pense que c'est
pas le moment et je pense que ça
avantage des gens qui n'ont pas besoin
d'être avantagés dans un anglais correct
béroul oui aussi avec les socialistes
et je pense que on peut pas à la fois
dire qu'on va réformer les urgences dire
qu'on va s'occuper des personnes âgées
en même temps les cds alors ça je ne
comprends pas et de toute façon pour ce
que ça entraînera d'investissements
futurs et de croissance peut-être je ne
crois pas en ce moment beaucoup bien
alors vous avez vu qu à une émission de
télé-réalité de politique réalité qui a
fallu ce faire sur sur tf1 avec monsieur
copé vous la ferez ses missions non on
n'a pas demandé non plus vous vous
demandez où sa santé
franchement non non non ah non non non
surnom mr va enfin c'est vraiment courir
au devant du ridicule c'est greg le
millionnaire tu le ferais
alors bernard vous avez remarqué qu'on
n'a pas encore parlé de christine
ockrent
jusque là je vous en remercie bon voilà
il a bien marché son livre a oui très
bien dans les têtes des ventes un livre
excellent 1 qu'il puise à gauche et les
kouchner
moi je dors à gauche ne l'est elle qui
paye le plus d'impôts elle qui fait les
courses en tout cas l émoi rarement à
des couches ailleurs moi j'ai un métier
difficile qui restent plus longtemps
sous la douche
moi qui se savonne pendant des heures
pour moi qui la savoie
pourquoi tu applaudis sérum ou même pas
gris voire magnéto rien qui prépare le
petit déjeuner bernard moi à oui mais
oui tu vois liée au scandale quand même
hein il fait tout à la maison c'est très
bien qu'ils aient pu soupe au lait des
deux mois qui allume la télé pour garder
tout le monde en parle
christine qui dit le plus de mal
d'ardisson écoute c'est très partagés
les deux se détestent euros non mais ça
ça s'additionne essaies tu l'as sommer
nul tu t'en sors dit obama
frédéric voulait poser une question
combien de fois par mois
accomplissez vous le devoir d'ingérence
dans christine il envoie l'onu et non
et le
voici le pied en chine enfin si pierre
balle mal
non
bonsoir pierre ça comment ça va très
très bien on est est ce que les
violences carré viiip là bas c'est quand
j'étais tout seul c'était pas mal mais
c'est que la bd est arrivé oui d'un
cassé je préfère revenir le plateau
comme frédéric vous avez passé vos
vacances
j'ai un petit village dans le var
balanceune maxime c'est ça alors dites
moi vous n'avez pas complètement perdu
votre temps à saint tropez je vais fait
une fête pour les soldats du feu n'ont
oui c'est neil régime qui s'est dit
parce que là on était en plein dans le
var ont mis les incendies ont fait rien
pour les pompiers finalement à part les
plaindre et le 18 août et on va essayer
de faire en sorte que tous les ans
le 18 août soit un bal pour les pompiers
ça va s'appeler le 18 c'est les pompiers
et communautés parce que oui alors effet
nous ça aurait été pour les
enseignements ont fait le 18 janvier
pour les banquiers par un des pompiers
régine la marraine
comment ça va se passer non non on a
juste lancé cette idée et puis voilà on
beaucoup de mères en france sont
d'accord pour que leurs villages et
leurs villes
le tz10 et 1c les pompiers n'en tue pas
tout of caritative de toute façon est
une bonne idée
jeudi l'accord c'est pas parce que c'est
pas votre idée maintenant c'est voulu
semer une fin sans frontières mais enfin
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne idée
la soirée des pompiers a été gâchée
quand même par une altercation de régime
non avec le dj luigi oui parce qu'il ya
des gens qui ont confondu une soirée
tropézienne avec une soirée à saint
tropez
c'est quoi la différence la différence
c'est que c'est une soirée populaire et
c'était pas une soirée pour pour faire
monter
trois pubs sur la table trois russes et
faire dégommer des bouteilles de
champagne c'était vraiment un bal
populaire pour les lanciers et régine
donc à vous lui file un coup de boule à
au dj et je les ai empêché j'étais entre
les deux et je crois que oui le résultat
s'est fait croire que c'était un sketch
et enfin bon en tout cas c'est
anecdotique parce qu'elle se bat là
rapporter beaucoup d'argent pour pour
les équipements et voilà c'est ça ne
peut être qu'un bon souvenir hier
car elle valait une conscience sociale
maintenant est ce que est ce que vous
êtes des nouvelles de votre partenaire
michèle laroque michel oui on se bat on
va régulièrement elle est revenue de los
angeles étant si elle fait des allers
venues bien supporté l'été quel bonheur
ce spectacle avec michèle laroque non
écoute écoute les gens m'ont parlé c'est
vrai qu'on fait un couple très crédible
on n'a pas d'idées pour continuer pour
l'instant à un troisième écoute pour
l'instant non et puis on ne va pas non
plus en faire une recette quoi donc
écouter pierre on a tellement aimé ce
spectacle qu'on a décidé que vous serez
le premier à entrer dans le panthéon de
tout le monde en parle
non ouais gaillot
[Applaudissements]
deux clients palmade induces prône ici
pierre toi et ton cortège de bons jeux
de mots nombre de sketches magnifique
voilà il mérite mais pourquoi n'y a pas
de kouchner il est vivant déçu berlin ne
pas être entré au panthéon petitclerc
regarde la tronche et non mais le
docteur kouchner il s'en fiche il a le
prix nobel de la paix oui enfin ça une
photo ici quand même oui en même temps
le prix nobel de la paix oui d'accord
d'enfer s'accroche pas vrai
moi je préfère avoir ma photo ici
bien sûr ça fait d'être le premier à
entrer au hall of fame de tout le monde
en parle
bon on sent aimé par ardisson et c'est
pas et y en a pas beaucoup qui peuvent
ils dire ça est-ce que ambiguë est ce
que le public a des questions à poser à
la pierre palmade aujourd'hui entré au
panthéon
ils s'en foutent complètement est ce que
vous savez qui suis-je
j'avais pas de question à peser à pierre
palmade ici non plus tirer rien voulu
dire à frédéric beigbeder à une question
frédéric ici non plus le bienvenu
[Applaudissements]
si c'est ton numéro de portable il a
déjà donné un bébé est ce que tu m'as
michel à tes côtés
mon panthéon même été la place tous les
deux
oui c'est vrai c'est pas venue de toi
spontanément j'ambitionne laroque de
vrais noms avant trait aux côtés de tout
le monde en parle il fait toi la rentrée
à part entré au panthéon tout le monde
en parle et vous déguiser en claude
françois j'écris un album pour rose
laurens à mémoire
qui m'a demandé d'écrire un album de
chansons pour elle et voilà et puis
écrire des chansons il ya dans les
sketches on peut pas tout on peut pas
dire des choses belles on oublie vers
des choses drôles et les chansons voilà
ça me permet de dire du romantisme ce
que vous avez en vous voilà que vous
excluez la chanson voilà le tour de ce
lot et puis j'ai fini ma de répondre à
thierry je reviens moi la fille je vais
tourner marie-anne chazel comme acteur a
fait plus que l'acteur maintenant je
vais pas chez l'acteur et puis je vais
écrire il muriel robin son nouveau
spectacle
ouais bien alors on dit souvent des
nausées sur les plateaux de télévision
et des fois même dans cette émission
alors je vous faire pierre palmade une
interview avec des bips
[Musique]
alors qu'hier c'est vrai que vous aimez
beaucoup faire après le spectacle
j'aimais au début et puis c'est fini
l'âge venant j'étais obligé pied en
amour vous êtes plutôt ou plutôt à la
pause toujours celle là
bah le bipe forcément ça vous a aidé
dans la vie d'être pour réussir à alors
j'hésite entre bobo ça peut être drôle
ça m'a beaucoup pays
vous connaissez bien michèle laroque on
vous a dit qu'ici même sur ce plateau
l'année dernière elle et moi on a des
taux courants oui vous l'avez vu à la
télé oui c'est possible et avec véro
vous avez oui malgré ce qu'on pense oui
et cette histoire avec on en parle on
peut en parler ou pas c'est n'importe
quoi
ah bon c'est n'importe quoi si je vous
dis vous pensez accrue à pierre
un bordel en régie
et
[Musique]
m
est ce qu'il ya des
sms qu'ils sont curieux de savoir qui
sera le prochain invité le suspense est
à son comble les gens sont tendus les
gens sont dans l'émission c'est une très
très belle rentrée malgré ce revers
immonde laurent d'autres sms
pas du tout ah non c'est non les gens
sont tous sur la lune parce qu'il ya un
petit temps mort mais on va tout faire
pour rattraper ça bien sûr on accueille
maintenant lyon là messieurs
miremont soir
histoire
et vous avez un look d'enfer lyoen un
incroyable cette clio 1 vient
d'accoucher et qu'en même temps il ya
trois mois
bah voila tu vois très en forme dans
laquelle âges de la vie voilà avec des
petites phrases comme ça qui mérite sa
photo ici bien lit ou d'anglet en scène
pour un spectacle vous chantez prévert
oui je chante du prêt du spectacle
enregistré sortie en cd à peu près sorti
en même temps que diego d'ailleurs et ça
s'appelle coeur de ruby 1 j'étais un
petit 10 comme ça où il ya tout votre
votre spectacle vous chantez quoi de
prévert sur ce disque je sens je chante
je suis comme je suis je chante embrasse
moi je sois l'état de très jolies
chansons prévert a écrit en rouge et
noir n'ont tête une bruno sire martinez
jeune va sur le plateau rythme on a
besoin de jeanne mas tu te démerdes rami
a très bien marché
servi
bien alors réservé une place formidable
soit prêt vers c'est j'aime sa manière
de parler de la noirceur de la vie sans
vous dégoûter ça m'a fait du bien c'est
vrai que les mecs bd parce que vous avez
parlé de prévert il a fait une
anthologie de la littérature française
il était et est bien classé prévenu
frederic à ce moment là
foutez moi la paix bien alors vous êtes
toujours chanteuse dont clio amène quoi
pas merci vous êtes toujours vous êtes
une chanteuse mais jour une femme mais
désormais animatrice sur arte vous
faites à un magazine féminin qui
s'appelle lola on y parle de kouadio des
sam le destin san destins de femmes qui
par exemple qui par exemple des inconnus
ah oui maintenant c'est les mecs mais
non c'est une fiche de juin vous dit en
parlant de la télévision que vous avez
des avis sur la télévision et c'est très
bien parce qu'elle est une citoyenne
vous payez votre redevance
vous êtes droit d'avoir des coureurs ont
bloqué les comptes d'heuliez aussi nous
dit on a tout loupé avec la télé
pourquoi on a tout loupé avec la télé
est ce qu'en fait elle aurait dû être
une fenêtre sur le monde et qu'elle est
qu un outil qui manipulent plus ou moins
bien les gens ouais ouais c'est vrai
vous avez dit vous avez dit
la télé manipulatrice propagandistes
racoleuse méprisante
ben oui et des fois vous l'êtes aussi
annoncé qu elle était restée sur le coup
parce que lio elle donne aussi des coups
de boule dont clio vous avez refusé nice
people malgré dix mille euros par jour
est-ce que c'était hôtel c'est que ça à
peu près c'était pas assez cher dix
mille euros par jour elle chantera les
ecchymoses et beaucoup moins est ce
qu'ils ont ils l'ont va proposer du maïs
l'épaule hélas avec à ce prix j'aurais
réfléchi bah oui ça l'est ça laisse
rêveur un 10000 euros par jour que les
gens ne se disent pas c'est une onde de
refuser 10000 euros par jour parce que
en acceptant ça elle peut aussi
jamais l'euro par jour avait fait un
calcul à long terme
souhaitons proposer sinon c'est à lui
d'aller dîner là bah ouais ouais alors
je suis pas allé je vais déjà un dilemme
frédéric quand vous leur proposez aussi
non voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire
on apprendra aussi j'ai refusé aussi et
j'ai vu à ce moment là qu'ils avaient
pris maïté à ma place est-ce que marina
foïs on lui a proposé mais non hélas il
a honte mais je me rends compte que ma
popularité est au plus bas
bah oui mais ça va mieux après le film
évidemment je leur ai fait elle était
prête à payer dix mille euros par jour
enfin dix mille euros par jour en ce qui
nous concerne ça aurait fait donc dix
mille francs par jour et par enfant et
c'était c'était pas mal ça aurait fait
déjouer au petit 1 voilà quand on vous
demande ce que vous avez fait autant
d'enfants vous dit mes enfants m'ont
empêché de mourir
les enfants m'ont rempli de quelque
chose de merveilleux peut-être une santé
un peu vide
ouais vous aviez besoin est rempli par
départ des enfants bien enfants
on peut vérifier la phrase c'est vrai
vos enfants combes et votre manque
d'amour voilà voilà c'est comme ça oui
c'est ça la phrase ça passe comme ça
maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux lio vous
avez retrouvé votre votre premier amour
oui c'est fou cette histoire c'est que
mais l'histoire était riche et clio a
retrouvé c'est son premier petit copain
à l'école 28 ans après le luxe et de
violence et de bruxelles à 50 ans plus
tard non mais c'est vrai nom à l'époque
qui vous dirige vraiment tout petit déjà
tué la femme de ma vie c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est dingue et lui disais on
finira notre vie ensemble à l'époque
lio rigoler ils sont en train de finir
leur vie ensemble j'en suis en vie
écoute c'est la télé qui nous a et c'est
parti c'était alors jusque là c'est vrai
vous le dites vous-même j'étais pas très
très doué pour trouver le grand amour un
banon ça ça se saurait si c'est dû à
quoi c'est dû à quoi
si vous êtes trop mou trop romantique
peut-être vous chercher trop un truc
beau oui j'aime maintenant je trouve que
dans l'amour yak l'absolu qu'un jour
j'en cherche pas la pluie franchement le
pire c'était le père de vos jumelles la
visite qu'il a été très violent avec
vous oui oui moi je suis aller de
charybde en scylla oui exactement
les droits pour en avoir parlé c'est pas
moi qui en ai parlé il ya vous savez
c'est la correctionnelle quand on porte
plainte et
et donc les journalistes tout le monde
peut venir dans la salle des codes
correctionnels ont assisté au procès et
il ya des mouchards dans les palais de
justice quand il ya des gens connus qui
se retrouvent en correctionnelle ils
préviennent les journalistes et j'ai eu
droit à une demi page dans le parisien
le lambrésien voilà c'est comme ça que
ça s'est passé et donc à ce moment là
j'étais pas du tout je n'avais pas du
tout envie d'en parler c'était quelque
chose qui était encore difficile pour
moi mais comme ç'avait été fait ben j'ai
préféré me parler m'exprimer et puis les
y ont fait une fois j'ai reçu tellement
de lettres de femmes dans le même cas
que moi que je me suis dit que j'avais
bien fait de le faire vraiment vous avez
dit ces hommes sont des prédateurs ce
type d'hommes qui repère les femmes
blessées et moi à l'époque vous étiez
blessé parce que vous êtes peut-être
moins de succès qu'à une certaine époque
et vous étiez une proie facile pour ce
type de ce type d'homme c'est ça il ya
un processus effectivement les hommes
qui
qui finissent par battre leurs femmes
d'abord ça se passe dans tous les
milieux il n'y a pas du tout un milieu
où les gens sont plus simples et où ça
se passe plus que dans un autre c'est
vraiment tous les milieux et est en fait
il ya sept indiens processus quand avant
d'en arriver au cou parce que ce dont
j'ai le plus souffert c'était qu'on se
demandait comment une femme comme moi
qu'ils avaient du caractère pourrait
vivre ça donc c'était quelque part je
l'avait bien cherché ou que j'aimais ça
et que donc j'ai peut-être d'une
certaine manière complices et ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'il ya de pire parce que
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se
passe son ce sont des hommes qui qui qui
ont besoin de la vitalité d'une femme
qui repèrent d'ailleurs des femmes de
forte des femmes qui sont solaire et qui
au départ leur déclare un amour inouïe
ça a l'air d'être vraiment l'histoire
d'amour du siècle c'est mieux que paul
et virginie
ils ont senti qu'il y avait une faille
en vous qu'à ce moment là vous êtes plus
fragiles bon mois cette époque là
j'avais 36 ans la quarantaine approchait
j'avais raté toutes mes histoires
d'amour je n'avais plus de contrat
j'étais effectivement assez assez mal et
au départ ils vous disent que vous êtes
la femme la plus merveilleuse enfin ça
l'est vraiment vous êtes la montagne la
femme de leur vie
et puis petit à petit la violence des
mares d'abord ils vous fâcher avec vos
amis vous fâche avec votre famille
dénigre le milieu d'où vous venez
dénigre votre passé est toujours très
intelligemment dix ans exactement les
choses qu'il faut et petit à petit vous
êtes seuls les scènes commence en
périphérie d'abord ça casse tout autour
et puis finalement il vous tapez tout de
suite après vous demande pardon et puis
vous allez deux coups en mardon de toi
pardon en espérant que vous allez
retrouver les jolies paroles du début et
si vous êtes aliéné c'est vraiment c'est
que ça se passe comme une secte ou 7
alinéa
quand je demande pardon vous
vous pardonner vous dit ça sera plus
parce que c'est pardonne jeu mais je
sais c'est sa mère mon père pardonne et
là on pardonne parce que d'amener kum
ben oui mais ça c'est évidemment ce qui
est plus difficile c'est de comprendre
ça c'est on a du mal à moi je me suis
senti extrêmement salies je me suis
sentie avilit et gémit j'ai vraiment dû
faire un énorme travail pour pouvoir me
regarder de nouveau et on pardonne parce
qu'ils sont en larmes directement après
qu'il dise qui regrette tellement mais
qu'ils ont été
c'est trop d'amour qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à gérer ça qu'ils ont souffert qu'ils
ont peur d'être trompé encore et on se
dit qu'à force de les rassurer qu'à
force de les aimer et ça s'arrangera et
puis ça ne s'arrange jamais ça ne
s'arrangera jamais et c'est de mal en
pis et la violence et escalade et vous
un moment donné vous est vidé de tout et
vous ne pouvez même pu réagir
qu'est-ce qui fait voter sur ce qui fait
mon sursaut c'est que ma soeur n'a
jamais lâché
lll a été voir et son ex femme battue a
parlé pendant trois heures avec un
psychiatre qui lui a expliqué le
processus et elle est venue toujours en
douceur toujours là et et elle me
racontait elle quand je lui disais mais
n'ont depuis cessé rien ça va s'arranger
elle me disait tu sais ça s'appelle la
lune de miel ça recommencera van dai au
début on ne veut pas y croire et puis et
puis finalement les petites sont nés et
continuent à me taper elle était aux
cinq donner des coups et pour les
enfants un moment donné on a un sursaut
parce qu'on se dit que vraiment le coup
peut partir n'importe où et un jour je
suis parti de la maison et j'ai été
porté plainte
guillot quand la mort de votre amie et
voisine marie trintignant récupérés par
des féministes au profit justement des
femmes battues est ce que est ce que
vous comprenez ça thierry je vais pas du
tout parlé de maritie excusez moi je
suis désolé je laime d'amour cette fille
je peux pas faire ça comprend moitié
[Applaudissements]
je ne tiens pas d'écrire un livre
ensemble oui absolument un livre
d'entretiens qui aurait dû paraître aux
éditions du cherche midi qui s'appelait
les hommes et les enfants d'abord sans
parler de marie trintignant
mais on en a bien compris en lisant la
presse que le problème était né de du
fait de revoir son ex mari en fait est
ce que est ce que vous donnez vous avez
revu vos anciens aux anciennes arrive
est ce que vous les voyez pas il y en a
des enfants c'est un lien extrêmement
fort quand on vous savez il ya une
phrase qui dit quand on aime plus c'est
qu'on n'a pas aimé un mois ce que je
crois c'est que c'est qu'à partir du
moment où il n'y a aucune ambiguïté et
bien l'amour doit être suffisamment fort
pour dépasser
vous savez quand on tombe très amoureux
de quelqu'un on a toujours cette espèce
de désir de virginité on a envie d'être
l'unique de ne jamais rien avoir connu
avant on souhaiterait tellement que
l'autre non plus n'est pas eu une vie
avant mais on peut pas le temps passe on
a fait des enfants et l'amour justement
quand il ya de l'amour ça doit aider à
dépasser ça il ya trouvé la sérénité
malgré un passé grâce même un passé
parce que ça nourrit et ça enrichit
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait trouver comme
sujet pour mettre les gens encore plus
mal à l'aise qu'hier on sera aux amis à
dar très hot spots larmes est arrivé je
comprends pas plus sympa mieux bien bas
alors voici maintenant
voici marina foïs
dans la bon soir
comment ça va bien
ra vous traversez en ce moment une
période particulièrement heureuse de
votre vie marine a d'abord au plan
personnel
au plan personnel votre vie affective et
particulièrement épanouie cet enfant non
c'est vrai lettre qui partage votre vie
est un être humain particulièrement
remarquable non je pense qu'une ici oui
donc question amour ça va je pense que
non mais ça se passe bien très bien très
bas la question argent ça va bien aussi
non et non un pognon fou pel cel pea et
c'est tout bobby wagner rer pour moi
vous avez acheté un appartement
oui il est bien il est très bien c'est
au c'est 12e rue de wagram oeil aux
codes ses 21 89
alors ça dans le voit la question est
maintenant ça arrive à bien beaucoup de
quel étage qui arrivent et laisser tout
seul tout un programme
sur le plan professionnel ça va encore
mieux vous venez de tourner le premier
film des robins des bois sous la
direction d'alain chabat
ça s'appelle très bien mais faut que je
m'entraîne à dire parce qu'on aura à
dire je pense j'ai quelques amis qui
l'ont vue est un grand r 4 petits airs
trois points exclamé voilà comment ça se
dit comme vous voulez elle a déjà tout
prévu pour la promo du film c'est réglé
bien alors il dans la caisse je vois tu
embrasses peau en cette semaine vous
êtes seul en haut de la fiche marina
dans un film de claude duty qui
s'appelle bienvenue au gîte
voilà alors là c'est une espèce d'extase
existentielle tout va bien dans votre
vie je crois que comme jamais quel
parcours depuis le début qu'on t'a connu
vraiment en bas de l'échelle
ça a commencé à amorcer avec un père
chercheur en physique mal golic au
départ c'est un handicap quand un père
chercheur en physique une verte si c'est
quand même vous étiez pas tellement et
des marinas et vous en êtes sortis
malgré tout et labouré qui me regardent
pas toujours eu la sensation de m'être
fait tout seul et je leur ai dit très
tôt ouais et alors ça évidemment
affreusement vérifier l'a compris celles
avantage mais bien sûr notre vocation
est née au contact on sait ce qu'on lit
par toucheront pas si c'est vrai au
contact d'un baby sitter c'est vrai ça
oui oui oui c'est vrai jean marc brisset
way qui était devenu depuis metteur en
scène va là bien sûr il est une
compagnie toulouse mais là j'ai commencé
à jouer des classiques la compagnie fait
au laos
c'était dans tous les journaux c'est
jean marc puissesseau a proposé à mme
arena alors le d'agnès dans l'école des
femmes à l'épée en suisse a continué
britannicus tous les classiques
les alignant rappelons le est alors
ensuite vous raconter ceux avec qui vous
deviendrez les robins des bois
nulle part ailleurs et puis au cinéma
alors je vais faire quand même meilleur
vous a vu dans la tour montparnasse
infernale voilà dans astérix mission
cléopâtre dans le raid
djamel bensalah dans mais qui a tué
pamela rose qui était un très bon succès
cet été
et puis dans un film de duty déjà
premier film vous avez fait avec lui qui
s'appelait filles perdues cheveux gras
c'était bien il y avait cette chanson
qui s'est généralisé
papa
c'est vous qui chantez oui maintenant il
existe une machine et c'est vrai vous
rentrez la voix de quelqu'un qui chante
faux et ça sort juste alizés bah oui ça
y est c'est vrai hélène ségara tout ça
dont la machine à huawei
alors vos rêves les plus fous se sont
réalisées marina je crois qu'on on peut
le dire non oui oui oui une partie
votre vie est au beau fixe c'est bizarre
je soutiens un gros dossier je vais
mourir à marina un moment de bonheur un
vrai moment de bonheur méline le
panthéon
non la pluie de pétales de roses didier
la promo alors oui oui faisons un peu de
promo voit la bienvenue aux gifs à
répondre à une question
voilà bienvenue au gîte ça s'appelle de
claude duty avec marina foïs philippe
harel
annie grégorio julie depardieu michael
malone et sébastien barriault beaucoup
d'or voilà au d'or voilà je vois que
monsieur est un connaisseur il est pas
mal il est bien monté sébastian oui oui
s'il joue dans les ch'tis métaireau moi
je m'en fous au maire de la magie du
direct bien je vais faire le pitch oui
hein alors la pastille ont tous les
facile c'est un couple en proie au
stress de la vie urbaine qui a décidé de
tout plaquer
il allait en provence pour reprendre un
gîte rural voilà l'histoire et
l'histoire on a tous ont eu envie un
moment vous aussi avec christine choisit
on a tous eu envie un moment de d'aller
en provence matin dans la loge qui m'a
dit moi je me tout laisser tomber monter
un gîte rural pas toutes les missions
qui pense souvent à vide montagne
vraiment fait des promesses de chair
alors quand vous arrivez dans ce gîte
rural tout irait bien à quelques détails
près d'abord vous vous avez jamais vu le
truc que vous avez repris votre philippe
harel lui il l'a vu il ya très très
longtemps
la vendeuse la fille qui vend elle est
partie avec un cracheur de feu sans sans
laisser d adresse en vous briefé il ya
un autre gîte dans le même blade quand
même vachement mieux que le vote voilà
et alors vous rencontrez en arrivant là
une fille qui veut pas partir qu'il a
angers lit quoi qu'est la bonne femme
qui s'occupe du truc qui s'appelle l'ami
gregorio et qui on a beau ni ce qu'elle
employait encombrante et qui veut rester
voilà donc tout ça n'est pas si simple
vous l'avez bien compris la clientèle
qui ne plaît pas beaucoup à caroline mon
personnage qui est pas très elle est ni
pour les scouts ni pour les actrices
porno que julie depardieu à merveille
riz pour les belges
elle rêve d'une clientèle un peu plus un
peu plus chic
selon ces critères à elle est
effectivement ça va être une sorte de
d'énormes ratage pour elle ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas autant ri un
chine a vu je n'ai vu avant que ça soit
deux jours avant et j'étais appelé celui
ci ça vraiment et c'est des jambes mais
comme il ya un bien dans un film bien
dans une comédie henry tout le temps et
en plus changé qui en fait ça dit
quelque chose
ce qui est rare dans les comédies et
c'est vraiment un jeu là c'est pas la
camaraderie mais y aller les yeux fermés
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble marié do
[Musique]
d'acheter ce gîte sens du tragique j'ai
vu plein de photos
couple une attention quelle raison
puisque dans l'argot ce n'est pas mon
genre j'ai des cauchemars tendance c'est
bien le drame est passés sans s'arrêter
de travail et surtout certaines choses
qui sont arrivées là des soupes marceau
ana
moi je
demain les conneries indienne à la
décharge bonjour excusez nous on s'est
trompé en cherchent l'autriche les six
mois là-bas obama
aussi un danger de concurrence non c'est
comme ça toi aussi t'es [ __ ] bon vent
par les points de la seringue samedi
quelque chose tu posera la question de
nantes à travers l'europe est en ordre
nous meurt dans une association
catholique qui tentent d'éloigner
d'anciens toxicomanes de la drogue vous
écrivez vos compères sophie autorisé
tournage d'un film x ici l'hôtel
d'appliquer le trafic électrique au gîte
c'est le concept logique qui le
chiffonne tant que ça finit pas à poil
dans les piscines contre dix scouts lépi
cousine des stars du x
c'est sûr fait la rondelle dans le haut
de gamme va mal le prendre mais là je
trouve super snobe pas moi qui vais
déléguer d'éclairer les châteaux pouvez
vous êtes sûr qu'il va pas pleuvoir mais
non tout va bien se passer
quand il pleut ou
au scrabble super tu nous laisses bosser
tu va terroriser quelqu'un de sympa
qu'il soit dans le gîte sacré j'aurais
jamais dû finir avec le soleil les
cigales avec entre autres marie
notre invité ce moralité de l'histoire
le couple ne se retrouvent pas donc
changer de vie à 40 ans vous dites qu'il
vaut mieux que ça reste un fantasme
finalement je trouve que c'est très
risqué et que peut-être ce truc de
changer de vie peut-être que c'est juste
un fantasme et qu'il faut pas le
réaliser mais peut-être qu'on se dit ça
quand on a une vie qui nous convient
c'est pas vraiment un rôle de
composition parce que vous êtes une
ruralité limité oui vous n'êtes pas très
campagne
non c'est un truc qui vaut non non je
c'est vrai que j'aime pas tellement les
prêts je n'aime pas les balades en forêt
les champignons accueillir les animaux
je crois que je m'en fous non c'est pas
c'est pas des trucs qui m'attire quoi
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien la vie
j'aime bien voir plein de gens j'aime
bien qu'ils aient des cinéma avec des
films en vo
j'aime bien pouvoir acheter des
cigarettes très tard vos loisirs c'est
quoi ces bricolages oui oui oui bah oui
je jeu j'aime beaucoup et je sais ya
sylvie testud qui va arriver aussi
j'aime tout ce qui est enduit coffrage
de tuyaux c'est une passion je trouve ça
très intéressant j'ai fait avec de
l'aggloméré j'ai chaque année mon père
m'offre un outil ponceuse perceuse rabot
et cetera
j'aurais là c'est mes activités par
exemple la chance votre jules ah ouais
et alors c'est bon ce personnage que
vous interprétez ramène toi elle sûr que
même quand elle s'occupe de julie
depardieu qui ne me sarr du porno qui
veut qu il veut décrocher
elle le fait parce que ça lui plaît de
se voir en train d'aider quelqu'un voilà
de trouver sa chique de fréquenter une
actrice porno
bref voilà c'est formidable de l'aider
dans lequel l'aide ouais elle ramène toi
elle est pour être actrice en fait ouais
ou animatrice de télé voilà un c'est un
truc comme ça alors c'est vrai on a tous
tendance et vous aussi nous tous à se
considérer un petit peu comme le comme
le centre du monde
oui oui j'imagine que le but c'est pas
ça le but c'est de faire un peu de lever
la tête c'est ce que j'essaye de faire
non je dis ça parce que vous avez dit
une phrase dans une interview dans un
journal que j'aime beaucoup et que je
vais essayé de m'appliquer à moi mais ça
fait partie des grandes résolutions de
la rentrée
il faut essayer de ne pas se subir
réfléchissez à quoi ça va être dur pour
toi tu es voilà le problème c'est pour
tuer une amende et l'histoire pour
permettre de purger votre égo on va
aller plus loin dans le nombrilisme de
façon à ce que vous fassiez comme on dit
dans le midi une fourre de nombrilisme
une fourre une fois oui il faut quand on
se fait une toile tendue une fourre de
chocolat ça veut dire qu'on bouffe du
chocolat thé prend on en mange plus de
quinze jours ça va se faire une fourche
de nombrilisme une overdose aussi au
préfet
à 11h02 bien et on va faire marina une
interwiew je me la pète
[Musique]
les derniers à avoir été soumis à
l'interview je me la pète été votre ami
jean paul rouve qui a été extrêmement
brillant dans un interview et je ne vise
pas que c'est mal
oui c'est bien dites moi ça vous gêne
pas d'être obligé de venir ici pour
faire la promo de votre film
non parce que tout ce qui peut me
permettre de parler de moi longuement
ennuyeusement mal est d'accord ça vous
ennuie pas moi demandez moi combien je
chausse si je me laisse pousser les
cheveux
qu'est ce que je bois le matin oui alors
ecafé bien est-ce que vous pensez que le
cinéma français vous mérite marina oui
il a besoin de moi en plus c'est vrai
est ce que j'imagine que votre talent
votre succès doivent susciter un certain
nombre de jalousie mon talent est mon
succès sont tout d'abord mérité et ceux
qui sont jaloux perdre leur temps
puisqu'ils n'arrivons jamais sous
l'onglet de machin appelé du bien c'est
vrai qu isabelle huppert vous demande
souvent des conseils oui mais alors
franchement et j pas le temps pour voir
perdre mon autre chose à faire bug je me
donne des conseils à moi-même fois là et
ça marche je me pose des questions je me
résous alors ça doit être insupportable
médiocrité des autres acteurs français
en pour vous une ipp surtout la
médiocrité des robins des bois à je n'en
peux plus de ce boulet à votre niveau
à votre niveau de jeu dans le monde ya
qu' il ya kidman et 2 miro avec une
perruque quoi c'est ou non
kidman ouais même pas kidman d'accord ok
j'ai fait une connerie là ça vous a vexé
que disque
il me semble que la comparaison est pas
hyper flatteuse pour moi moquer marina
ok ok bien marilyn quand même île morte
janot est morte aussi vous avez vous
avez quoi que les autres n'ont pas été
ni chance à je sais que non
le reste ouais si on vous avait dit
qu'un jour c'est vous qui jetterait brad
pitt est ce que vous auriez cru à
l'époque ça oui mais alors brad pitt
j'ai couché avec lui pour lui rendre
service parce que c'est pas du tout mon
jour et c'est vrai gg pardon j'aime pas
les blancs moi j'ai une couleur j'aime
beaucoup des nouveaux cheveux je les
trouve très bien c'est des vrais cheveux
tu les grands noms parce que moi je
cherche un peu beaucoup d'enfants bière
non mais ça m'intéresserait de ces
mélanges de bière
justement que sur de suite mais je
prends une mèche à 400 euros 3 nouvelles
je te la mets devant sa femme marina est
ce que c'est vrai que vous coupez sans
arrêt votre portable parce que les
réalisateurs vous appelle
c'est vrai soderbergh spielberg un
chabbert tous les blogs
qu'est ce qui vous reste comme objectif
dans la vie maintenant mais rien je
crois qu'il est temps que je me retire
d'arriver au sommet là en haut de la
vague il faut partir marina foïs la
maison
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle bien
à la regarder et on va tous et elle va y
aller ça donne envie
ouais c'est très bien on passa à tout le
monde s'en mêle vivier alors tout le
monde s'en mêle le courrier d i télé
spectateurs donc daniel vives de
toulouse il me semble que l'on baffie a
en lui des potentialités non encore mis
en oeuvre il fait preuve de beaucoup de
sensibilité et de discernement
il ya tout à fait raison ce garçon est
censé je dis pas ça parce que c'est mon
cousin ça n'a rien à voir
il est temps que les gens dans ce pays
qui ce qu'il réalise que je tourne à 10
pour cent de mes possibilités voilà
c'est très bien laurent vous êtes
invités en nouvelle calédonie par ryu
szyszka fils dépasse je le connais c'est
un con il hors de question de faire deux
jours d'avion pour voir un blaireau
pareil six jours au sujet de la nouvelle
calédonie tout fallait yorkey de la
section autochtones ôter au caté au hand
autochtones le premier groupe de rap
canadien non le premier groupe a les
qualités
le premier groupe de rap calédonien
merci bernard kouchner ses gardiens ce
cas il faut on confond avec
[Rires]
bien
alors 2010 et alors il a dit quoi les
dernières de calédonie est ce qu'il
advient il nous dit bonjour oui mais
attendez vous rendez compte qu'en
nouvelle calédonie et des milliers de
gens le samedi soir devant l'autre oui
il m'a invité pourquoi finalement j'ai
peut-être parler il était invité en
nouvelle calédonie oui pour faire quoi
la ba ba pour faire ce que tu veux tu es
invité enfin des vannes chez lui
d'accord je vois ça doit être bon la
maintenance est magnifique elle nouvelle
calédonie magnifique leurs oignons
l'ancien était pas mal plus dur est déjà
là ils ont préparé une nouvelle mon
vieux bien alors de 00h01 ferry un
casting regardera le raid
on va le garder au mont terri ami tu me
fais rire c'est pour ça que tu es là de
bien lire les orges il dit chérie tu es
l'homme sur lequel fantasme de mes amis
américaine quand elle te vois sur tv5
comme quoi l'éloignement parfois a été
agressé en amont des personnes on
l'appelle le mal des pays on s'accroche
à n'importe quoi
deux retours de tours dit je voulais ça
maintenant il est vrai n'en ont cure et
ça c'est [ __ ] pour l'apercevoir
c'est une contrepèterie c'est quoi ça
vidéo le four deux tours il sera obligé
si la gc je voulais simplement te
remercier je ne sais pas mais c'est vrai
je ne sais pas ce qui arrive à ma copine
mais chaque fois qu'elle te voit sur
l'écran
il lui prend d énorme envie de sexe et
ce n'est pas pour me déplaire
et si elles n'ont pas du tout aller
sinon les faits qui sait quoi non mais
c'est se caressent le samedi soir en
regardant qui rien genre qui se
caressent pas si on regarde la femme de
la femme de ludo or four
comment ça va lui donner nous regarde
lui ont remis ce travail là il faut pas
lui
donc là ça va repasser à reporter sans
frontières vous connaissez reporters
sans frontières est absolument
alors lundi 29 septembre soirée kouba si
castro nos au théâtre du rond point des
champs elysées avec catherine deneuve
sophie marceau pierre arditi bernard
kouchner
lio pierre palmade et marina foïs et
laurent baffie
bah oui je vais y aller non monsieur
bernard cinéma pour voir so bernard
d'éclat sans frontières il y va je sans
frontières il était allé je répète le
lundi 29 septembre donc au théâtre du
rond-point des champs-elysées à 18h30
avec catherine deneuve sophie marceau
pierre arditi et nous tous
voilà parce que castro encore mis des
gens en prison il a mis déjà en prison
des intellectuels il les a condamnés
entre 14 et 28 ans et il en a il fut pas
si les guillotines mais enfin il ya eu
trois condamnations à mort pour des gens
qui étaient partis et en français
toujours des gens comme wolinski régine
de forges qui défendent castro
défendeurs jeunesse ouais normal comme
chute sinon un
dans la sienne elle est bien cette chute
on m'a gardé cette chute
[Musique]
il m'arrive bien
mais ce soir
j'accueille maintenant frédéric
beigbeder
[Musique]
c'est lui qui m'a vu mais non
catherine il a bu trop de votre cas mais
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire catherine
un compte rendu
on va faire une consultation à la il
s'est arraché leur torche et il a bu
trop de votre katana que j'avais dit pas
boire il peut l'aider on peut vraiment
catherine hill de vraiment pas fuir
[Applaudissements]
il est
couché par terre dans la
ouais
épluchez partir dans la loge de france à
pékin non c'est pas une blague dénoncée
canon il est couché partant à l'âge
catherine en phase avec bd mais
catherine ébouriffant 4 et catherine
labouré du tout il ne peut pas venir
c'est sûr chercher elle me dit quand on
veut me on peut pas parler d'un exercice
maintenant j'espère que vivien il vient
samedi prochain quand même ont failli je
sais que je vais le décor n'est pas très
beau mais on est quand même bon bah
écoute voile annoncé qu'il était pas
bien quand on était encore en amont
avant tout d'attirer et j'ai eu un
sentiment qui a trouvé torche et je les
trouvais un petit peu particulier bien
bon bon bah écoutes je vais libérer liu
d'abord qui doit allaiter ses six
enfants ils pas tous à la fois mais au
moins au moins le bac bd
valliot
ça
et
salut l'eau
c'est la première fois que ça va rires
vu j'ai vu des gens ne pas venir à
l'émission mais des gens venir et se
trouvait dans la loge est incapable de
rentrer sur le plateau servira que le
type est assez spontané comme il n'est
pas inutile et entend retenue bien ben
écoute frédéric cros mais toi j'espère
que ça va mieux
amélie occupe toi de lui j'accueille bob
r
[Musique]
non
bonne mère dont soir je suis libre
martyre et leurs actes n'ont pas encore
il a laissé par touches ou bien alors
vous avez 50 ans bob berre et vous êtes
un ex-cadre de la cia
quand vous êtes entré la cia en 1976
pourquoi un jeune homme chic habitué à
faire du ski à aspen et à faire des
voyages en europe at-il postuler pour
entrer la cia et au sort de leur mère
oui c'était super romantique de voyager
ça a mis du piment dans ma vie d'un
moment j'ai pris goût dans la salle de
bain nous agirons
mais bon c'était l'expérience mais pour
pas comme ça derrière
comment vous vous appelez monsieur
olivier un bon soir olivier soit bien
alors pourquoi avoir quitté la cia vingt
ans plus tard
vous voyez la cia s'était trop politisé
et donc j'avais l'impression de perdre
mon temps et donc j'ai tenté ma chance
ailleurs bien alors pendant vingt ans
vous avez combattu l'islamisme sur tous
les fronts c'est surtout sa déroute à
sarajevo en irak 95
j'ai essayé de faire tomber sa dame je
vais monter une petite équipe peu au
nord de l'irak malheureusement ça n'a
pas été un succès dépêche toi un peu
olivier lassus apple se foutent bien
alors le livre de le vivre dont on va
parler ce soir c'est votre deuxième
livre bob le premier s'appelait la chute
de la cia qui était un best seller aux
états unis et qui va être bientôt adapté
au cinéma par soderbergh pour la warner
voilà c'est pas c'est pas n'importe qui
alors votre nouveau livre s'appelle l'or
noir et la maison blanche comment
l'amérique a vendu son âme pour le
pétrole saoudien essai publié chez jean
claude lattès
une question est ce que la cia sait des
choses que les présidents ne savent pas
où est ce qu ils obligés de tout dire au
président oui quoi de temps en temps il
ya certaines choses qui se passaient les
présidents sont pas au courant mais bon
ça on n'en parle pas du tout et c'est
très rare mais bon je peux pas tout vous
dire je suis de modifier j'aimerais bien
alors le pitch va vous révéler bob burke
il ya un pacte qui unit les élites
économiques et politiques américaines à
la famille royale saoudienne voilà en
gros c'est ce qui ressort de votre
curseur de votre bouquin alors dans
votre livre des passages qui sont
supprimées et des passages qui sont
caviardés alors vous les avez vous les
avez laissé mes mais barré quoi c'est à
dire vous êtes obligé de montrer tout ce
que vous écrivez la cia de la cia il a
fait du regard retire certains passages
l'essentiel est là et je remercie
laisser y aller alors il y avait quoi
dans ces passages barré dans les années
70 dans les années 80
il y avait un soutien officiel des états
unis aux fondamentalistes islamistes
évidemment contre l'union soviétique
l'afghanistan c'est un exemple que nous
connaissons tous les états unis ont
volontairement essayé les
fondamentalistes c'est ça qui a été
barrée d'enlèvement qu'est-ce qui a été
barrée dans le livre où il
principalement ccc lien ces liens qui
existaient dans le passé et qui sont un
petit peu gênante à l'heure actuelle
alors bob r votre livre dédié à daniel
pearl qui est le héros du dernier livre
de bernard henri lévy dont il est venu
parler ici alors bernard henri lévy
attirer l'attention sur le sur le
pakistan vous c'est l'arabie saoudite
alors l'arabie saoudite très simplement
pour nos amis téléspectateurs c'est un
quart des réserves de pétrole du monde
et c'est vrai que l'arrêt de
l'approvisionnement en pétrole saoudien
serait la mort d'une grave crise
mondiale
c'est pour ça en fait que depuis très
longtemps il ya une alliance entre les
états unis et l'arabie saoudite qui a
été signé au départ entre roosevelt et
le roi ibn saoud
en gros c'est ce que vous appelez
pétrole contre protection et la deuxième
raison de cette alliance c'est que les
saoudiens l'islam en général était un
rempart contre le communisme du temps de
la guerre froide c'est ça et c'est ce
qui explique ce que vous appelez dans
votre bouquin l'aveuglément américain
par rapport à l'arabie saoudite
hier à wall et oui absolument en fait
dépendance totale de l'économie
américaine vis-à-vis de l'arabie
saoudite
prenons par exemple une grève au
venezuela les puits pétrole sont fermés
à ce moment là qui va compenser l'arabie
saoudite évidemment qui qui appuient
américaine tout simplement à l'arabie
saoudite dans la mesure où c'est leur
premier acheteur arabie saoudite investi
des milliards de dollars dans l'économie
américaine
vous savez dès lors qu'il ya
accoutumance il est difficile de voir
les choses en face et donc il ya un lien
qui date d'une cinquantaine d'années
entre l'arabie saoudite et les etats
unis pour des raisons qu'on a vu et
depuis le 11 septembre la réalité est
apparu aux yeux de tous c'est que la
famille royale saoudienne est totalement
corrompu un complètement corrompu et
pour garder le pouvoir
elle finance des extrémistes c'est ça
c'est ça l'histoire a commencé par al
qaïda c'est simplement garder le pouvoir
il la verse de l'argent aux
fondamentalistes pour se protéger et
puis le redis fait de révolution
ailleurs en afrique en asie en indonésie
ou ailleurs mais pas ici est bon le
mieux la meilleure c'est que ça a marché
ou du congrès mais en fait il n'y a pas
eu de difficultés en arabie saoudite
le problème en fait c'est à washington
si vous voulez savoir toute la vérité
mon avis c'est que washington voit les
choses tout à fait différemment et donc
le 11 septembre les américains ont été
surpris de voir qu'il y avait quinze
ressortissants l'arabie saoudite dans
ses avions alors lénine avait dit les
capitalistes nous vendrons la corde pour
les pendre
finalement c'est un peu ce que font les
américains puisque l'attentât du world
trade center étaient financés finalement
et de l'argent américain d'une certaine
façon absolument vous savez que l'argent
utilisé 11 septembre
dans le cas des attentats du 11
septembre avaient été prélevés en arabie
saoudite etc et ensuite ils été
réinjecté en fait on fait son plein on
fait le plein de sa voiture de sa
voiture et bien on donne de l'argent al
qaïda bien évidemment on peut toujours
aussi le savoir qui fait quoi et tu sais
mais bon c'est un fait
bernard tout ça est et à gérer tout ça
est vrai pour
le pétrole mais le pétrole n'est pas
seulement l'argent américain c'est
l'argent du monde c'est notre argent
c'est l'argent tous les pays nous nous
fournissons également en arabie saoudite
mais ce qui est très étonnant sens
bouquin c'est pourquoi les américains
sont ils victimes d'un un tel
aveuglement et ben vous dites parce
qu'ils sont corrompus eux aussi bien sur
le recyclage des pétrodollars mais aussi
tout un tas à washington de lobbyistes
de cabinet de relations publiques
d'avocats vous dites par exemple ceux
des petits exemples mais le roi fahd
envoie un million de dollars à barbara
bush pour ses oeuvres en faveur de
l'alphabétisation par exemple vous dites
aussi une histoire qui est bien pire que
ça c'est qu'un jour cachot guy va dans
le ranch de nixon à san clemente en
californie
et puis en partant et l'oubli une valise
avec un million de dollars à l'intérieur
personne là lui réclament
il en déduit ils en déduisent que
finalement washington et à vendre quoi
quelle est la solution pour régler le
problème de l'arabie saoudite à l'art au
départ on se dit la démocratie la
démocratie viendra à bout de de tous les
problèmes mais vous dites aujourd'hui
que s'il y avait des élections libres en
arabie saoudite finalement contenu la
nature du pays ça serait des islamistes
qui seraient élus et l'arabie saoudite
vraiment un pays comme comme comme
l'iran de khomeiny par exemple je pense
que c'est un peu prématuré pour ce qu'il
faut mettre en place en arabie saoudite
et l'état l'état de droit il faut
essayer d'aider les classes moyennes
pour qu'il y ait un accès un droit à la
propriété
c'est une première étape nécessaire
et puis il faut aussi se débarrasser de
toute cette corruption
c'est vraiment c'est ridicule ouais vous
dites bottes berd ont finalement la
démocratie c'est pas la solution donc la
solution c'est quoi c'est l'intervention
militaire contre l'arabie saoudite
le devoir d'ingérence écoutez à la fin
du livre je fais un petit raccourci je
dis que si le pays fait faillite et bien
ce moment là on peut pas
ce pays parce que on a besoin de ce
pétrole pour des raisons de sécurité
mais ce qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait cédé
réformes au sein du pays il y a une elle
qui soit réformer le pays c'est celle
représentée par le prince héritier est
ce que c'est beau père est ce que c'est
parce qu'ils sentent que l'attitude des
etats-unis à leur égard est en train de
changer
que l'arabie saoudite se rapproche on
l'a vu cette semaine se rapproche de la
russie je pense que l'arabie saoudite se
rend bien compte que en train de dire
clairement que dans les relations entre
les deux pays est une superpuissance qui
d'un coup tu que tel un dinosaure pour
elle et je pense que l'arabie saoudite
est en train de rechercher de nouveaux
alliés que ce soit la russie où l'europe
ou les états unis n'oublient jamais où
il ne faut jamais oublier que les états
unis ont été profondément blessée par
les attentats du 11 septembre c'est un
fait les américains inquiéter vraiment
touché il est clair aux yeux des
américains et aux yeux du reste du monde
d'ailleurs que tout le monde que nous
ayons sûr réagi en quelque sorte
et donc on se rend bien compte que cela
a affecté leurs relations avec l'arabie
saoudite alors que quand vous parlez des
états unis ce qui est le plus inquiétant
à mon sens c'est que vous dites qu'ils
sont tellement corrompu par l'argent
saoudien qu'on voit pas très bien
comment il pourrait s'arrêter d'être
aveugle et d'une certaine façon
alors qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
aux états unis un sursaut mais les
médias aux états unis maintenant sont
présents brigade et on voit bien il n'y
a plus qu'une seule voix qui parle
il ya aux états unis de plus en plus
d'arrestations arbitraires l'habeas
corpus qui est la base de notre
démocratie et est remis en cause des
états unis alors j'aimerais vous poser
une question bob r une question qui a
été posée cette semaine à la une d'un
magazine qui s'appelle marianne qui est
le magazine de jean françois kahn
bodmer est ce que vous croyez
sérieusement aujourd'hui que les
etats-unis sont encore une démocratie
[Musique]
ah oui mais
la peine encore une attaque et cette
attaque pourrait avoir des dommages
irréparables des conséquences très
graves
je pense que tout le monde s'en
inquiètent donc l'amérique est à peine
une démocratie dite vos états unis sont
toujours une démocratie mais s'il y
avait une sacoche de plus à ce moment là
on pourra certes en hausse de 3,6 par an
déjà le cas à l'heure actuelle mais y
aurait par exemple ce serait par exemple
la fin du premier amendement est un gars
t'es de la presse la presse dans une
situation délicate à l'heure actuelle et
les choses pourraient les choses
pourraient empirer mais espérons que tel
ne sera pas le cas
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle le fils de votre père en
noir et maison blanche damart non c'est
quand même curieux qu'on s'en aperçoive
maintenant tout le monde sait depuis 25
ans que les saoudi les saoudiens
persécute ou le monde que les droits de
l'homme ne sont pas respectés que les
femmes peuvent pas conduire que tout ça
est épouvantable découvrir cela
justement un prêt à fonctionner mais les
femmes ne connaissent pas c'est pas mal
bernard soccer
[Applaudissements]
sauf que maintenant en plus on découvre
qu'ils financent d'al qaïda ça tout le
monde le savait c'est avec eux qu'ils
ont fait l'afghanistan les talibans et
cetera donc on découvre pas ça
maintenant parce que c'était vraiment la
fable lanjard balma un livre comme ça
vous vous a créé des ennemis dangereux
ce serait difficile d'en faire la liste
voyez vous il ya tellement de gens qui
sont furieux
furieux voiture est une invitation
non en fait ma famille et au proche
orient
les gens ne vont pas chercher à se
venger contre une famille proche orient
mais bon c'est ma responsabilité je
l'assumé plus amère si mal merci bernard
je voulais c'est parti avec bob 12h
d'amour s'agit du moyen-orient du liban
merci beaucoup
bernard il n'a pas dire au revoir il
faudrait qu'ils soient pas dire bernard
oui bernard oui t'as pas dit au revoir
aux mêmes heures
oui le fait urbain
le regard
pendant un film
ces trous là il est là
[Musique]
la main
ciao
comme ça
et ça c'est de la merde
bernard est venu on rappelle bernard
c'est perdre aux arènes avec béziers iv
une eau après katrina pas réapparaître
avec bd bien même catherine a disparu
situe donc la manne quand je croise par
hasard on est au bout comme par hasard
bien marine en bar se voir maintenant
quelqu'un qui est qui et spécialiste en
gage de lascaux mo cache un paquebot
messi68 estimé la clé
la cuisse on vous a vu dans les
blessures assassines stupeur et
tremblements fils unique avec sandrine
kiberlain et on vous retrouve dans le
dédale de rené manzor avec lambert
wilson frédéric diefenthal michel
duchaussoy et thomert 6 les voilà et
puis vous publiez un livre excellent
d'ailleurs chez pauvert qui s'appelle il
n'y a pas beaucoup des toiles ce soir
voilà on va commencer à voir le film
voulait bien un
alors le film le pitch c'est un petit
peu la revisitation du mythe du
minotaure c'est vous connais minotaure
laurent animal mythologique à la miami
toro qui est rien de labyrinthe à dire
un bras lors c'est ça exactement très
bien laurent ils nous regardent chez lui
de son oeil attentif et a donc soumis ce
mythe du minotaure et revisitée à
travers une tueuse en série atteintes de
troubles de la personnalité multiple 1
en fait cette personne se partagent le
contrôle de son corps
c'est ça quelqu'un qui se prend un tour
à tour pour différentes personnes voilà
alors ça peut être des hommes des femmes
de différents âges voilà exactement
c'est comme docteur jekyll et mr hyde
mais y en a cinq autres évidemment c'est
un rôle idéal pour une actrice dont
j'imagine d'avoir à payer cette fois
plus
non c'est vrai pouvoir passer d'un
garçonnet de sept ans apeuré à une
tombeuse qui se laisse pas marcher sur
les pieds à un homme un peu un peu macho
ultra violent ce matin mais ça fait ça
oui elle passe en plus en une fraction
de seconde d'un personnage à l'autre
c'est extraordinaire pour une actrice
non oui c'est une chance inouïe mais
c'est à dire que c'est il faut passer le
père on a peur un petit peu de faire un
numéro de claquettes de faire un numéro
d'acteur il faut trouver
quelque chose qui fait que vous y croyez
et surtout dans chaque personnage feu
trouver les paradoxes qui à chaque
personnage est entier voilà marié tôt
[Musique]
histoire de plantes est une histoire
c'est un des cas les plus étranges la
psychiatrie moderne
pas de cadavre pas que témoin
sans la victime une affaire glauque quoi
comme tu les aimes chez vous
la loi tient
[Musique]
bon ça chez moi
quelques jours
un signalement des signalements way
contradictoire est ce que tu as déjà
entendu parler de personnalités
multiples tandis qu'ils me traitent de
personnalités gens mais pour certains
c'est une femme pour notre salon on est
des personnes personnes qui répondent
plutôt prenant clown c'est pas plus cool
parmi les cinq reprises de tubes le quai
en plus vous tuez dont je n'aurais pas
la réponse à cette question on tournera
en rond c'est beau
[Musique]
dédale de rené manzor sortie le 10
septembre donc avec sylvie testud que
notre invité ce soir
oui c'est un film très psychanalytique
d'une certaine façon non en fait c'est
un polar quand même et voilà un thriller
et lambert wilson fait un psychiatre qui
essayent de décès en fait ce que moi je
suis un serial killer
il essaye de voir si je joue la comédie
ou si je suis réellement posséder
réellement atteinte psychologiquement et
en fait cette maladie existe réellement
moi j'ai vu des documentaires c'est les
gens qui ont dix sept personnalités
moi j'en accepte ouais et des gens c'est
encore plus rapide que les changements
que moi je fais comme ça sert que je
regardais les documentaires et je me
disais mais c'est pas possible il faut
vraiment qu'on me dise que c'était vrai
il ya une dame par exemple qui dans un
supermarché allemand est alors allez y
les dames tout à fait normal et tout à
coup elle se prendre pour une petite
fille qu'à quatre ans et regardez quand
le plectre en dix ans 1
je voudrais manger des corn flakes et
elle se met à courir et à danser dans le
supermarché son mari est très mal et la
rive à la caisse non mais c'est surtout
aussi qu' elle a deux petites filles qui
d'un coup ont compris que leur mère a un
problème elle se met à jouer avec leur
mère comme si c'était leur copine et la
mer les disputes
enfin s'il est bien guéri ce nom ils ont
pas réussi pour l'instant ils essayent
seulement à diminuer le nombre de
personnes et surtout comme ils souffrent
énormément
ils ont souvent une personne qui leur
veut du mal qui voudrait terminer tout
ça et qui essayent de les tuer toi c'est
quoi la schizophrénie et parfois
multiples alors l'autre actualité c'est
le livre alors on vous savez bonne
comédienne sylvie testud
mais là ça nous en bouche un coin ses
fins élégants ces subtiles c'est bien
écrit
non mais c'est extraordinaire c'est que
c'est pas du tout l'autobiographie
l'auto glorification qu'on attend au
qu'on peut lire
généralement quand un acteur ou une
actrice ou quelqu'un comme ça écrit un
bouquin qua non en fait son démon
ce sont des détails que j'ai vécues
m'ont marqué et en fait à la base je
voulais pas écrire vraiment un livre ce
qui se passe c'est que ça quand vous
faites des films vous êtes souvent
absent deux mois il ya main ou cissé
c'est soporifique de raconter ce qui
s'est passé deux mètres de moi sur une
table et de raconter par les gens que
personne ne connaît et un moment je me
suis amusé on m'a offert un ordinateur
portable à écrire ça et écrire les
situations un peu rocambolesques dans
lesquelles on nous mais je donne un
petit exemple comme ça mais c'est vrai
qu'à un jour à 7 heures du matin dans
les loges il ya un cascadeur qui vient
et qui me dit est ce que tu sais sauter
par la fenêtre
alors je dis bon côté c'est pas vous
c'est quoi cette question je rejoins pas
et c'est à dire que tout le monde était
absolument désolé parce que je refusais
de sauter par la fenêtre y avait cinq
mètres de haut voilà c'est dit moments
comme ça il est la fille qui a sauté
s'est cassé les deux jambes vers la case
kabyle cédant deda c'est dans des dalles
sa lessive a marqué dans mon livre je le
sais vous la paix était un petit peu
comme un refuge et 5e
assez extraordinaire dans ce bouquin
c'est des bouts de vie à cette
expérience un petit peu comme sadrau
drolatique de votre existence de deux
femmes
j'ai des trucs formidables à la première
journée au conservatoire par le
conservatoire la preuve que vous appelez
les patentes lui dit tu aimes ton corps
montsalès
il ya aussi un casting avec un
réalisateur qui se la joue et qui vous
dit pour être actrice il faut manger de
la merde pour chier des étoiles qu'est
ce que tu veux répondre ça vous avez des
gens qui vous disaient des trucs comme
ça vaut non moi j'ai eu un satyre mais
un vrai un type qui se faisait passer
pour le casting de jean jacques beineix
qui donnait rendez-vous dans des cafés
et qui proposait d'aller faire des
essais donc pour une scène décrivait la
scène en disant c'est une scène dans un
duvet tué en peignoir et tu te caresse
un moyen très alléchants comme senna
juin et après ils demandaient d'aller
faire les essais chez moi voulait pas le
lire c'est très très très bien écrit
c'est un exercice extrêmement difficile
mais comme c'est vous qui l'avez ces
défis
[Applaudissements]
ouais si une scène d'amour et quand on
fait une scène d'amour on doit être
maquillé un petit peu partout est ce que
quand vous avec la tête qui est
maquillée ça va pas quoi voilà il
souvent menés avec des gens qu'on
connaît pas donc je dis ce matin la loge
est fermée à clé normalement la loge
maquillage est un lieu de discussions la
loge maquillage est un lieu de détente
ce matin la loge maquillage est fermé
sauf y installer une serviette éponge
sur le sol normalement sophie m'installe
sur un fauteuil devant son miroir
aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui je dois
tourner une scène d'amour toute la
journée jeux de temps les nuits ce matin
sophie doit maquiller le visage et le
corps j'ai été mordu par un chien
stupide à l'âge de 12 ans une vieille
histoire que j'avais presque oublié
aujourd'hui si ce chien est toujours en
vie il a de la chance de ne pas se
trouver dans la loge maquillage
quelle vision elle doit avoir je pense
donc je continue je passe un petit peu
mais tu crois que ça va se voir je
demande sauf y en a c'est non je crois
pas je vais poudre et s'il faut on fera
un raccord ferrara corps je sais ce que
c'est moi ferrara corse et recommencer
sur le plateau faire un raccord c'est
refaire le maquillage devant tout le
monde
jeudi on n'aura pas besoin de raccord
s'il voit cette marque là c'est que la
caméra elle a eu mal placé jeudi sur
deux mois je n'ai pas du tout peur je me
sens dans un jour faste
ça va être une très bonne journée je
vais jouer nu avec un garçon que j'ai
jamais vu je vais me coller à lui je
vais fermer mes yeux je vais respirer
très fort parce que je le désirait plus
que tout je vais faire du bruit parce
qu'il va me donner du plaisir c'est
écrit dans le scénario
je vais avoir du plaisir pendant huit
heures ce n'est pas donné à tout le
monde je pense ma mère qui est comptable
n'a sûrement jamais de plaisir comme le
mien derrière son bureau avec ces
chiffres c'est toujours rassurant de se
dire qu'on a dépassé la condition de ses
parents
[Applaudissements]
passer des pigmentations comme ça
excellent ou alors on fait une idée
géniale c'est avec et la carte de bons
clients
oui à qui tu donnerais une carte de mon
client n'a marina qui est vraiment une
très très bonne cliente wind est ce
qu'on peut avoir la carte de bons
clients
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai une carte bien marqué bon
client dessus mais c'est alors la carte
de bons clients
non non c'est aussi pendant méline enfin
la carte
excusez moi c'est la ceni n'est pas une
bonne cliente enfin tu penses qu'il veut
la donner à marina attend c'est déjà pas
mal j'ai fait quatre cinq émissions de
télé que marina je me fais une émission
avec elle sans me marrer au moins une
fois jamais donc d'accord jusqu'ici une
carte de bong allait se passer
grâce à cette carte tu peux revenir ici
quand tu veux sans sont inactivées
week-end à tout problème de baffie même
si t'as rien donné la pierre
là
oui
qu'est ce qu'elle te disais la non j'ai
dit que c'était pour voir notre carte de
bons clients de lire comme l'a fait
c'est un exercice
ouais si oui est ce qu'on peut avoir une
carte de bons clients poursuivis eux
sont ou non on ne revient avec bd et
voilà on viendrait quand vous volez sens
parce qu'on va voir les gens qui vont
revenir enfin il y en a qui vont s'en
servir cette carte va là sylvie testud
pompignan voilà d'ailleurs tout donné
c'est la définition du talent de sylvie
testud mans et bien écoutez là c'est
quoi as tu avais mis sur pied la diva je
vaux mieux que moi je l'avais oublié
mois déjà elle dit que c'est c'est un le
talent c'est un truc inventé par un mec
pour empêcher son frère de faire le même
métier que lui
ah oui oui c'est vrai que vous dites ça
et vous dites aussi que quand on un
comédien ou un acteur qui joue pas ben
c'est pas c'est pas un acteur en fait ce
qui fait la différence c'est que
l'acteur c'est celui annoncé celui qui
joue non non non non non non non non je
dis pas ça le dit un acteur vous vous
êtes acteur sauf que vous n'êtes pas
engagé sur un film pour jouer la comédie
mais tout le monde peut être acteur et
que le mot talent c'est vraiment un mot
on met tout sous quoi c'est tout allait
reprendre sa carte
et maintenant alors là maintenant tu vas
voir à ces normes
beck bénin n'ont pas beigbeder phyllis
il est rentré chez lui apparemment est
maintenant endémique
[Musique]
voici ci jackson
cindy jackson mesdames messieurs alors
si ni jackson c'est votre vrai nom mais
vous n'êtes plus connu sous le nom de
michael jackson barbie acquis depuis
1988 chine dit vous vous efforcez de
ressembler 47 opérations de chirurgie
esthétique et vous avez osé faire ce que
personne n'avait osé faire avant vous
c'est à dire une modification intégrale
du visage et du corps y compris au
niveau de la structure osseuse mais oui
voilà entre la cindy du départ et la
barbie d'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
rapport c'était pour ressembler à barbie
ou pour être plus belle que vous pensez
être pour être plus belle main parce
qu'en fait on me taquinait toujours dans
ce que je fais à petit à cause de mon
menton etc
je ne venais pas du bon endroit dans la
ville mes parents étaient pauvres
je suis en fait je rêvais à une vie plus
glamour c'est uniquement pour être placé
pour avoir une autre vie serait
peut-être plus facile de ressemble à un
telle et hubinon ces conseils vous
donneriez un enfant qui veut se
transformer en train électrique
et vous vous leur donniez qu'une console
moi rester naturel moi j'aime beaucoup
la fille de gauche
vous n'échapperez pas cindy de toute
façon à l'interview barbie
[Musique]
alors comment vous faites comment vous
faites pour vous habiller le matin et
jusqu'à une petite fille qui vient à
vous habiller le matin est ce qu'une
petite fille qui vient à vous habiller
le matin comme vous et maintenant vous
êtes une poupée barbie
winkel petite fille s'amuse d'ailleurs
si vous voulez dire qu'en redemander
c'est vrai mais vous l état des replays
with you est ce qu'on peut lui expliquer
que c'est un jeu on joue à l'interview
barbie et qu'après on parlera
sérieusement ses pieds ok loin de tout
en fait
maintenant je comprends dans un aliment
français
[Musique]
alors comment vous faites pour vous
habiller le matin jusqu'à une petite
fille qui vient vous habiller non c'est
ma mère qui le thème tout comme votre
monde maintenant commenté le voir et si
je vous coupe les cheveux est ce qu'il
ya un bouton ou je peux appuyer pour que
ça repousse bien ça dépend du bouton sur
lequel vous appuyez l'a compris
est-ce qu'ils avaient toilettes chez
vous non il est pas juste pas mais
[ __ ] dit comme votre copain qu'elle ne
savait pas qu'il est un peu con quand
même non mais bon c'est à cause des
accessoires comme tous les hommes
je ne
bien alors cindy vous êtes né en 1955
dans une petite ville de deux fermiers
de l'oieau et vous avez une enfance dans
une communauté assez souvent au milieu
des champs de maïs et vous rêviez et
enfants d'une vie plus plus glamour à 6
ans vos parents vous offre une poupée
barbie qui devient le support de vos
fantasmes c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé en fait c'est un peu comme un
talisman pour moi c'était le symbole
d'une autre vie pour moi et je me disais
qu'il devait bien y avoir une autre vie
plus loin que les champs de maïs
moi je ne voyais que la vie des paysans
des ouvriers
je travaillais dans une étudiante voilà
moi je ne sais pas très bien où aller
c'était à la fin des années 50 et en
1959 j'ai ma première poupée barbie est
pour moi elle représentait tout
simplement quelque chose de totalement
différent
et à cette époque barbie ne portait pas
tous ses habits très très brillant aux
roses
en fait elle portait des habits de mode
avait beaucoup de classe et maintenant
la barbie c'est quelque chose de
totalement différent
à barbie moderne n'est pas du tout ce
que j'avais à l'esprit à l'époque alors
à l'époque vous voulez vous évader de
cette petite ville un petit peu
étouffante et puis aussi vous évader de
votre corps parce que vous aimez pas
votre corps quand vous êtes enfant vous
semblez plutôt à votre père avec les
traits un peu un peu un peu rude qu'à
votre mère en fait cela ne me dérangeait
pas de ressembler à man bancaire mais
j'avais vraiment un air sain masculin
tandis que ma soeur ressembler à ma mère
est en fait ils être atteints de manière
tellement différente de moi en me
traitaient comme quelqu'un d'inférieur
hamas heures en fait c'était toujours ma
soeur qui réussissaient tout aussi je
faisais une erreur elle aussi et bien
c'est moi qu'on grondin est en fait elle
avait vraiment les villes différentes à
cause de son apparence physique et je
savais que ça ne concernait pas que ma
soeur je savais que toutes les filles
mignonnes et est vraiment différente
deux mois alors qu'aucune personne ne
s'intéressait à moi j'étais invisible
n'existiez paris c'est vrai et en 77
vous quitter les états unis pour londres
où vivait toujours au début vous faites
delà de la musique et en 1988 à la mort
de votre père vous recevez un héritage
et vous commencez les opération
chirurgicale destinée à vous faire
ressembler disons à la haye la poupée
barbie
je n'avais jamais pensé à la chirurgie
esthétique avant d'avoir de l'argent
parce que j'ai toujours dû travailler
beaucoup pour avoir de l'argent et
jamais je n'aurais pensé que j'aurais pu
réaliser mon rêve
mais le
au moment où j'ai réalisé que j'avais
d'argent bien je n'ai pas hésité et je
n'avais pas peur de travailler très dur
j'étais ambitieuse
je n'étais pas stupides j'avais de très
bonnes notes à l'école mais ce qui me
manquait c'était l'apparence physique
donc immédiatement je me suis dit je
n'ai pas très envie de voyager d'acheter
une grande maison d'avoir des déshabille
très bon en fait je voulais vraiment
être ben je je me demande si vous avez
un enfant si vous en avez on ne vend pas
vous ressemblez je suis trop âgé pour
avoir des enfants maintenant donc ça ne
posera pas mais j'ai pensé au départ je
me suis dit hé bien moi toute façon je
ressemble et permanent non plus donc bon
ils pourront ressembler à leurs points
mais je n'aurai pas de ses enfants elle
peut de faire opérer pour qu'ils
ressemblent à que nous abordons dans 20
ou 30 ans comment vous visage de
l'avenir et bien jor-el la même
apparence physique maintenant c'est tout
l'espace entre nous vous avez remarqué
aussi je sais que cindy michelle en moi
m
pas mal eh oui pourtant certains c'est
noël ce soir dites moi c'est une ville
c'est vrai vous avez eu une aventure
avec james hewitt l'amant de lady di
est-ce que vers l'extérieur on change
l'intérieur c'est bien ce qui se produit
c'est qu'en fait ça change les autres et
de personnes parce que les autres
personnes nous regardent différemment
vous êtes un même personne un intérieur
je vous sentez de la même manière et
vous agissez la même manière mais les
autres personnes deux traits de manière
totalement différente et nous faisons
tout cela en fait il est vrai il y ait
un millionnaire qui était très mal
habillés à ce moment-là à bien vous et
moi nous diriez que qui ne vaut rien par
contre quelqu'un de très beaux et bien
et bien si cela change tout on regarde
les personnes
et puis on se fait une certaine idée
on a des hypothèses sur ses personnels
ces personnes là et bien leur apparence
physique leur tenue vestimentaire contre
simba dickie parler d'elle et pas compte
de tout ce que vous pourrez que dans
l'avenir tout le monde se fera opérer et
bien c'est quelque chose qui se fait de
plus en plus si nokia
quand même c'est trop long regardez
quand même regard mais il faudrait qu'il
arrête de mentir c'est toujours pas un
mot de ce que veux tu as besoin de
mentir et laurent à incroyable je joue à
la poupée
this is an bénévoles vous pensez quoi
cindy ou pensez quoi de chair et bien je
l admire beaucoup elle est très belle
elle et moi je trouve très sympa qu'en
pensez vous moi je les ai connus quand
j'avais 18 ans elle était déjà la très
jolie maintenant j'ai beaucoup plus elle
est toujours la très jolie
donc je considère que c'est un bel
exploit vous pensez quoi de michael
jackson je les ai rencontrés et vous
savez il n'a pas eu une enfance très
heureuse et je crois qu'ils soient sans
sentir très différents tout le monde et
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qu'il
veut exprimer par son apparence en fait
ce sont probablement très bizarre à
l'intérieur de nos ils sont sympas les
pokémon pikachu et les commandants la
ville
le
voilà c'était cindy jackson alias barbie
merci d'avoir été avec nous
thank you going to stay champions 2000
il ya un mois son mouvement j'accueille
maintenant fatou diome
[Musique]
bonsoir photo john bond soit vous êtes
32 ans est née au sénégal
vous habitez strasbourg où vous êtes en
doctorat de lettres modernes et vous
publié chez anne carrière un livre qui
s'appelle le ventre de l'atlantique
c'est l'histoire de saly qui comme vous
est né dans l'île de niaux d'or au
sénégal qui vit à strasbourg divorcée
d'un blanc et qui fait des études et
comme vous s'allie à un frère qui rêvent
de venir la rejoindre en france c'est un
peu la même histoire
c'est un petit peu autobiographique on
peut dire je pense alors le frère c'est
madické qui est fou de football et pour
qui la france est une espèce de d'el
dorado
il rêve en fait de venir habiter en
france
oui en fait saliver en france et puis
comme beaucoup de jeunes africains il ya
madické qui vit à new york une petite
île du sénégal et sur le dans le village
on l'appelle maldini parce qu'ils les
foules de maldini également et il ne
rêve que d'une chose c'est rejoindre sa
soeur anne europe et devenir comme ces
stars multimillionnaire du football
évidemment c'est un voeu pieux pour un
enfant du tiers-monde
voilà alors ils rêvent évidemment ils
sont 20 est entretenu par tous ceux qui
sont revenus au pays au sénégal qui ne
parlent que de richesses en oubliant les
humiliations la précarité le racisme
en fait il ya un personnage qui
s'appelle l'homme de barbès donc il
habite à barbès il a fait tous les sales
boulots tous les petits boulots ils
étaient mal payés intérimaire tout le
temps sauf que l'été y parfaire son
pacha intérimaire sous les tropiques
donc il entretient le rêve et moi je dis
c'est facile de débarquer avec une bonne
paire de nike et puis un bon team qui
vaut très cher quand on a mangé des
pâtes et puis des pommes de terre toute
l'année c'est très facile d'aller faire
fantasmer des jeunes qui n'ont jamais
rien vu d'autre
qu'est-ce qu'on leur montre à la télé
parce qu'évidemment on ne leur montre
pas la vraie vie des immigrés ainsi donc
je voulais aussi analysé le rapport
difficile entre les émigrés qui sont en
france et leurs familles restées au pays
parce que les membres de la famille au
pays ils ne se rendent pas compte que
parfois leurs attentes sont démesurées
donc quand on est en europe et on en à
mamie apporter soyez nombreux
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour éviter ça
j'ai senti d'éternuements je suis parti
et c'est encore pire alors 11 et moi
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant à la
vie de la poudre de perlimpinpin j'en ai
plein le pif sais pas si extraordinaire
de homs en fait sauvé pour sauver son
frère
sally essaye de détruire le mythe de la
france elle dorado et c'est ce qui est
très intéressant dans votre livre c'est
à dire c'est l'immigration mais vu du
côté vu du côté africain s'est revus vue
de là bas effectivement c'est vrai que
quand on quand on est un immigré
convient en france qu'on envoie des
mandats au sénégal etc ont fait vivre
toute une famille ce qui est un petit
peu une obligation nous dit d'ailleurs
on devient une espèce de héros
et quand on revient c'est ce que vous
racontez au sujet de l'homme de barbès
on peut épouser qui on veut en fait
c'est vrai quoi on épouse même plus le
prétendant émigrés retour réponse de la
france
donc quand on se marie avec la france on
peut tout espérer donc il ya des gens
qui ne savent pas qu ils peuvent pas
habiter n'importe où en france et que ça
coûte très très cher et ça n'a rien à
voir avec le niveau de vie qu'on a au
pays et donc finalement c'est presque
plus facile de les aider à réussir sur
place qu de les amener ici que votre
part d'autobiographie mais moi je dis
toujours pour m'amuser
on va dire 80 % ça ne peut pas se
mesurer aux mains nues la mode c'est
bien parti
donc je dis ça parce que je pense que le
premier sacrifice de l'écrivain comme
disait quelqu'un s'est lui-même
donc je parle de mes expériences et
aussi d'une révolte intérieure je pense
que ce ne sont pas des lois qui vont
changer l'immigration c'est une
nécessité de francis des immigrés
eux-mêmes
moi jamais je n'ai pas de dire que je
faisais femme de ménage en alsace pour
payer mes études à partir du moment où
on dit ça c'est vrai qu'on perd en
luminosité
on n'est plus aussi enviée on n'est plus
aussi admirer on est plus adulées du
tout mais en revanche on expose la
vérité telle qu'elle est oui alors
l'homme de barbès lui effectivement
quand ils arrivent au sénégal même quels
que soient les boulots qu'il ait pu
faire en france il dit mais la france un
pays formidable n'y a pas de pauvres en
france il dit par exemple bien que tout
le monde a le rmi donc il dit tu passes
ta journée à baillet devant la télé et
on te file
le revenu maximum d'un ingénieur chez
nous est donc revenu maximum de neige et
niort chine
voilà donc voilà il parle des
allocations familiales aussi dit chaque
nuit d'amour est un investissement
évidemment parce que plus on a des
enfants
tous ont gagné de pognon il dit il
suffit de faire des enfants pour être
payé à rien faire beau la vie quand même
ceux qui ramassent qui ramasse les
crottes de chien à paris sont payés par
la mairie sont payés dans le monde quand
on sait qu'on peut être là bas et
travailler dur dans les champs et nous
rien gagné à la fin du mois et imaginez
ramasser quelques crottes de chien à
paris pour être riche
évidemment ça fait rêver ça prend des
proportions ça prend des conventions
mythique est en fait en réalité vous dit
cet homme de barbaise qui friment comme
ça quand ils retournent au sénégal il a
dormi dans des bouches de métro il a il
a chapardé pour manger il a survécu
grâce à l'armée du salut et puis là il a
il a tenu un marteau piqueur pour son
territoire il avait appliqué le marteau
piqueur d'un jour par toutes les saisons
donc il a dû tout supporter sauf qu'une
fois au pays
l'image dorée son respect fait qu' il
n'a pas envie de révéler la vérité et
moi je pense que ce n'est pas seulement
une analyse de l'immigré c'est tout
simplement la vanité humaine
donc personne n'a envie de dire ce qu'il
a enduré sur son passage pour venir
pourraient être au sommet
donc c'est à nous les immigrés de dire à
nos frères ce congrès avant puisque ce
qui est très touchant dans votre bouquin
c'est qu'en fait il a fait tout un tas
de métiers terrible il a une vie
terrible cet homme de barbès et à un
moment il a vraiment réussi quand il est
devenu on peut dire un cap au cirque
anti la coque quand il devenu le
contrôleur de ses semblables
oui parce qu'il est vigile donc je dis
les passes et deux maîtres chien chien
du maître l'a donc quand il voit ses
semblables ses frères d'itinéraires où
ils sont trop arrogant pour faire leurs
courses dans les supermarchés donc ils
les trouvent trop arrogant pour faire
leurs courses comme les blancs ou alors
ils les trouvent trop pauvre pour être
honnête donc toutes les manières
cantonné type et on est louche a priori
mais oui et c'est à cause de ça que je
dis aussi c
c'est semblable qui l'arrêté ils ont
fini par comprendre aussi un exil
le plus terrible pour l'étranger en
france ce n'est pas seulement le top-ten
raciste c'est aussi notre qui a envie de
changer de camp et qui se donne tous les
moyens pour ça et qui finit par oublier
d'où il vient assez extraordinaires sont
donc un ses dunes c'est d'une précision
chirurgicale sur l'immigration c'est
très très fort vraiment alors au
chapitre des humiliations vous raconter
l'arrivée de salies mais on peut penser
effectivement que c'est vous à 80% en
france elle est autorisée à rester au
départ parce qu'elle est pas mal à dire
qu'elles passent un examen de santé qui
lui coûte quand même une certaine somme
320 francs et elle est autorisée à
rester parce qu'elle n'est pas malade et
c'est exactement ce qui se passait du
temps des esclaves
vous dites ça très bien c'est à dire que
à l'époque de du trafic d'esclaves on
ceux qui étaient malades dont les
éliminés ont regardé que ce qu'était le
tessin est bien portant et la france se
comporte aujourd'hui une certaine tout à
fait légalement comme un négrier
j'ai dit à l'époque où on vendait
pêle-mêle le nez dans les bennes et les
épices personne n'achetait d'esclaves
malades
donc maintenant il faut savoir que la
maladie c'est une tare rédhibitoire pour
l'accès au territoire français il faut
passer une radio intégral moi quand je
suis arrivé j'ai dû passer cette radio
intégral et j'étais très pudique elle
adore me disais mais si vous voulez
rétablir vous n'aviez qu'à rester chez
vous avec je ne suis pas venu en france
non plus pour être à poil 1
enfin pas tout le temps disons c'est
dommage non ça dépend avec qui
alors vous ces sites là je parle plus de
l'héroïne du bouquin salim et je parle
de vous faites tout vous est pas venu en
france pour faire fortune détenus en
france parce que sénégal vous aviez
rencontré un jeune coopérant dont vous
êtes tombée amoureuse vous dites là
quand un mec vous regarde dans les yeux
en me disant je t'aime à pau night on
sait tout sur l'exercice il est
difficile de résister et alors vous avez
épousé ce français et vous êtes une
erreur de casting en fait une erreur de
casting les couples mixtes ne marche pas
à vous dit non ils peuvent marcher mais
ça dépend avec qui fois il faut être
assez construit pour ça moi je trouve
qu'un comprimé que c'est un idéal
d'ouverture tout simplement ça
correspond à ce que j'ai dans la tête et
je peux le vivre ça ne me pose pas de
problème parce que j'en arrive à oublier
la couleur de l'autre c'est dans le
regard des personnes qu'on rencontrait
que je me rendais compte en fait qu'on
était différent et en fait c'est une
erreur de casting parce que quand je
suis arrivé les siens attendait blanche
neige
eh bien vous était complètement rejeté
par la famille hewitt c'est pas une
histoire de culture parce qu'on dit
souvent c'est une histoire de culture
mais vous la culture occidentale vous la
posséder parfaitement cette des études
de lettres modernes
enfin bon vous êtes quelqu'un de très
attentif à la culture occidentale ont
eux mêmes pas dire que c'est ce à quoi
ça marche pas parce que ça ne peut pas
marcher racisme j'ai souvent entendu
dire que les parents se dit fallait les
vents se disent oh là là nos
petits-enfants vont être métisse quoi
n'ont pas donné de riom dans la famille
c'est là à ce que j'entendais
quotidiennement classe alors que vous et
je disais les trios gosse je disais que
j'étais intéressé par la culture
occidentale
à peine arrivée vous avez sur la tombe
de chateaubriand à saint malo à peine
arrivé en france alors qu'il y est
écrivain mais pour vous c'est
inimaginable devenir écrivain c'est
quelque chose de participer vraiment là
du du mythe c'est le cas de le dire du
rêve est alors votre mari français
alsacien voulez pas vous écriviez
sa famille non plus il voulait même pas
que je devienne proche des français ce
qui vous attend ma naturalisation par
mariage est sorti il a refusé de la
signer donc on a fini par me l'a refusé
j'ai dû me battre après des années tout
seul parce qu'il ne voulait pas que je
puisse passer le concours du capes pour
enseigner le français
donc j'ai continué et puis chaque année
je demandais la nationalité on me la
refuse et je faisais un autre diplôme on
me refusait encore la nationalité je
faisais un autre diplôme donc j'ai
atterri un doctorat par hasard mais
c'est thomas martin lück à queen
exactement est ce que c'est vrai que lui
les bleus tellement pas que vous
écriviez qu'il est parti un jour avec
votre manuscrit le premier est magique
quand on a réclamé ça parce qu'il ya eu
un procès et où il n'a jamais voulu le
rendre
il dit qu'il l'a détruit qu'il a aussi
détruit les disquettes puisqu'il avait
aussi abîmé l'ordinateur il fallait pas
que j'écrive vous pensez une négresse en
plus intello qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
donc il est parti avec et quand j ai
réclamé ans j'ai mon avocate qui s'est
battu elle n'a rien pu récupérer puis
moi je leur ai dit laisser tomber quoi
il a tout emporté s'offre au cerveau
dont elle peut continuer vous êtes en
proie au racisme dont on est des phrases
du genre une femme chez qui vous allez
chercher du boulot à un moment qui vous
dis toi y'en à comprendre madame je veux
dire que en 2000 et quelques ya encore
des gens qui vous parle comme ça moi je
dis qu'il ya peut-être des occidentaux
qui aurait des leçons à tirer de
quelques vadrouilleurs du tiers-monde
comment je viens de matières molles mais
j'avais déjà vu beaucoup de pays
européens parce que quand je faisais des
ménages je m'offrais des voyages
jusqu'aux états unis
c'était pour m'ouvrir la tête donc quand
vous tombez sur une dame qui n'a vu que
sa campagne natale
il a beau être naturalisé français à
avoir toute la culture de faim de base
de victor hugo il n'a rien de plus qu'un
been sédentaires beugnot moins
[Applaudissements]
mais la libye les lignes qu'il ait vu
une fois rentrent dans la forêt des
trucs en imaginant des bandes dessinées
donc on peut pas imaginer qu'en dise
lors du france info et là vous êtes
formidables faut dire les choses comme
la vous avez beaucoup de brou
d'intelligence évidemment c'est que vous
dites que vous êtes la pitié pour ces
gens-là et qu'en fait vous êtes plus
choqué par le racisme sournois des gens
qui disent j'aime pas les étrangers mais
toi je t'aime bien parce que tu étais
toi là donc c'est le racisme pour moi le
plus terrible parce que quand quelqu'un
de pseudo cultivez vous dit ça il a
l'impression de vous élire son estime
c'est justement le moment où moi je le
déteste parce qu'en fait quand il dit je
n'aime pas les étrangers mais toi tu es
différentes moi je voudrais qu'ils se
demandent ce que les étrangers pensent
de quelqu'un d'aussi belles que lui 1
c'est à lui j'arrive très sain alors on
va terminer sur une phrase de vous que
dans votre livre que j'aime beaucoup
pour finir vous dit partir c'est devenir
un tombeau ambulant oui mais vous vivez
comme ça avec votre théâtre d'ombrés
dans la tête quoi c'est de venir dans
tombo ambulant où les vivants et les
morts dont l'absence en partage parce
qu'on porte en nous nos familles qu'on a
laissé derrière nous on porte en a nous
aussi nos morts nos souvenirs d'enfance
et tout ça est en nous mais personne ne
peut le voir et moi à travers ce livre
je voulais aussi raconter des destins il
ya des personnages qui traînent leur
destin et je voulais pas receler vous
dire aussi aux occidentaux
quand vous regardez un étranger regarder
l'histoire humaine qui a derrière tout
le monde n'est pas venu voler une tarte
à la crème c'est ce que disent et
volcans ici
la saison dernière il disait que quand
les américains arrivent en irak
ils se rendent pas compte que des gens
qui sont en train de bombarder ont cent
mille ans d'histoire derrière c'est
exactement ça et je dis parfois on dort
tranquille parce que les cris des autres
n'arrivent pas jusqu'à nos oreilles
merci ça fait du bien
dieu mais ça s'appelle le ventre de
l'atlantique c'est publié chez anne
carrière
c'est magnifique merci vous restez avec
nous on passe maintenant à une nouvelle
séquence de l'émission qui s'appelle
tout le monde en rêve alors c'est une
séquence qui est consacrée chaque
semaine aux nouveaux talents
et cette semaine nous accueillons
juliette arnaud
[Musique]
il
bonsoir vous êtes arnaud donc vous étiez
dans carré viiip avec frédéric beigbeder
oui vous avez lu donc comment il a un
truc avec la vodka tonic
je pense qu'elle est frelaté à 1 donc je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de servir de la
vodka tonic
mais sinon il allait bien et d'un coup
bam alors pour votre tout le monde en
rêve vous avez choisi une épreuve assez
difficile je dois dire vous avez choisi
d'interviewer laurent baffie ici
présents l'interview s'appelle c'est
l'interview celui qui fait son pire par
celle qui suit sa pente
didier
allez-y non le titre est une petite
explication en fait c'est parce que ma
maman est prof et elle a des types
particuliers d'élèves et il ya les
élèves qui font de leurs pires par
exemple les élèves qui suivent leur
pente
les élèves qui s'applique ce qu'ils font
de leur mieux et vous vous êtes
typiquement le mec qui fait son pire
alors j'ai bien dit observer c'est
raccord avec ce qu'on me dise à l'école
moi j'étais exactement l'élève inverse
je suivais ma pente à dire je faisais à
peu près ce que j'avais envie de faire
pas plus par mois mais je ne parle pas
de provoquer en fait il vous avez jeté
votre dévolu sur moi pourquoi parce que
je me suis dit tant qu'à me ruiner
hauteur et que le pire soit passé au
passeport voilà six au moins ces nobles
ça fait la chute mais noble bref donc
j'essaie de réfléchir a avoué il ya un
truc qui m'est venue m'a alors assez
rapidement j'ai noté 3 chaude chez vous
qui m'intéresse vraiment et qui je pense
intéresse à peu près tout le monde
votre vivacité qui va avec donc la
provoc
le fait que vous avez l'air pur in
angoisses et le fait que vous êtes
extrêmement pudique et ça ça m'a rappelé
un numéro peu de nos bottes le freestore
oui je sais c'est très bien vu juliette
je vous encourage à continuer à pied
alors j'y vais et vous m'avez fait
penser à quelqu'un
le personnage qu'incarne james coburn
dans les sept mercenaires les lanceurs
de couteaux et les questions je lance
des couteaux dans un one-man-show
prochain donc tout c'est pas idiot ce
qu'elle dit le fut non mais c'est vrai
il ya un truc extraordinaire c'est que
un à peu près la même époque dean martin
je crois qu'il a inventé le type cool
c'est un mec qui est cool
dean martin était cool ils n'en avaient
rien à secouer de rien et vous souvent
quand on voit sur un plateau de télé on
se dit que vous n'avez rien à secouer de
rien ce qui sans doute faux mais c'est
une impression ça fait le mec cool c'est
pas comme ça c'est pas sympa oui parfois
ya des choses qui m'intéressent et
parfois
non donc voilà par exemple il est très
intéressé par bateau c'est vrai et ça se
voit aussi nommé james coburn ya des
moments il est super intéressé tout d'un
coup il se réveille mais son chapeau il
balance un couteau mais pas dans le dos
jamais james coburn c'est un antihéros 1
c'est un mercenaire
un merci dans c'est pas un mec bien
forcément en fait on se rend compte que
comme tous les autres mais sept
mercenaires
enfin les six autres c'est un mec ya un
énorme coeur bien sûr de normes
est ce que vous faites le même truc les
sept mercenaires c'est à dire que sans
arrêt sans arrêt vous faites exprès de
jouer le truc je suis pas un gros je
suis pas un mec bien
ceux qui passent leur temps à répéter
d'ailleurs les 7 mars avant tout serait
ravie d'être un héros et j'essaie d'être
un mec bien ce que je suis pas tous les
jours
je suis à ses clients pour être un héros
mois s'est passé passé très pas
tellement ce que vous faites ressentir
donc parce que là je fais d'autres
choses mais j'ai pour ambition de
changer le monde mais bon là je n'ai pas
le temps pour l'instant t d'autres le
font à ma place mais oui je pense que
j'ai des projets pour sauver la planète
avec sa mère avec d'autres copains et
c'est là ma secte est en préparation
massey week sur la première cet anti
sectes et on ira nettoyer des rivières
car des trucs comme ça l'argent pas
d'argent ils n'assurent pas d'argent
jamais et un autre peut situer proche de
james collins et james cameron dans les
sept médecins c'est pas le chef le chef
c'est ce qui habille en noir si yul
brynner olalalala il paraît également
que vous êtes appuyons pourri d'angoise
si on m'a dit ça on dit que voter c'est
l'arrêt cardiaque à chaque fois juste
avant de monter en scène
qu'est-ce qui nous mais ça va mieux je
jouais 450 fois une pièce ça m'a
beaucoup beaucoup soigner on m'a dit que
vous étiez un mec il y avait des
angoisses pas possible alors un jour un
prof de théâtre m'a dit qu'ils étaient
pas beaucoup plus vieux que moi m'a dit
je pense à la mort tous les jours moi
j'ai pas doute métaphysique
je suis pas ce que ça veut dire penser à
l'amour tous les jours je voulais savoir
si vous vous faisiez partie de ces gens
qui pensaient à la mort tous les jours
comme tous les comiques comme pierre
comme tous les cas mais je crois qu'il
est inhérent au métier de comics quoi
cécile n'ose pas la morale en jeu au sol
je n'en sais pas davantage ou non se
sentir vivant c'est justement c'est
justement c'est savoir comment moi non
non non non je pense que si on fait un
tour vous n'êtes pas bien en tout cas
d'accord de taille le top chez les
comics vous verrez que viala
alors qu'est noël en régie directe en
m&a d'accord ok je suis la seule à ne
pas penser à la mort très très bientôt
temps et enfin la dernière chose vous
êtes d'une pudeur enfin par rapport au
reste des gens qui font à peu près le
même métier que vous vous êtes plutôt
pudique et ça c'est aussi c'est très
proche de l'esprit des sept mercenaires
puisqu'il parle quand même beaucoup par
signe un camp estime quant à lui le
brenner on lui demande où il va il
répond ça quand on lui demande d'où il
vient il répond ça et vous c'est un peu
pareil
exactement si tout à coup je me mets à
vous poser des questions super personnel
vous me répondrez parce que je trouve
plutôt bien voilà je crois que j'ai
peut-être question posée avec juliette
alors vous oui julia d'être comédienne
mais on peut vous voir en ce moment dans
arrête de pleurer pénélope au palais des
glaces
voilà re succès ça remplit même pendant
l'été même pendant la canicule n'a fait
la canicule ou alexandra climat non non
ça me 38 degrés sur sa non hamilcaro m
il ya eu des femmes qui ont fait des
sortes d utiliser des tirs de cris au
premier rang un peu mais j'avais de la
peine parce que comme nous on
transpirait vachement elle je crois
qu'il avait tellement de pitié nous
tirer c'est disait aux gens venez pas ce
qu'ils ont à faire
elle trouve ca c'est beau hein donc tout
l'été ça a été plein de tout l'été sa
marge lâchement bien haut le pitch très
simplement ces trois trentenaires du
troisième millénaire qui enterre la vie
de jeune fille d'une quatrième qui ne
viendra pas voilà il ya eu en attendant
godot arrête de pleurer
donc on va ce blind test ce soir en
blanc une thèse consacrée aux chansons
qui donnent envie de se suicider didier
vous connaissez une possible intel et
chante
oui c'est vrai je sens qu'ils donnent
envie de se suicider je veux juste
l'interprète c'est très facile
didier pas fini didier
[Musique]
chatel
je crois le premier set
je
auj
ils ont divorcé a plombé l'ambiance en
gare à ça même s'ils sont gras qui a
marqué des points la méline nous devions
toi non non et 1,6 ici parce qu'à une
réponse qui a été donné par le public
ici donc je reviens là je pensais que
c'était pas la peine de rappeler les
règles du jeu mais apparemment il
faudrait le faire tant pis
quand quelqu'un souffle dans le public
ici le point bas et inversement du passé
pour nous c'est normal
à qui tu attribues le premier point bas
toi nous non il l'a dit il ya vingt
civils a dit avant toi ouais mais bon on
va faire 1 1 et puis 5e 2e des deux
héros pas attention didier avec le
périphérique longtemps
c
ajustez dire ça fait 3 assez sarrola
didier lastère serge lama suit
didier valet a
dalida
[Musique]
ça va ça il est mort et dix mois et
vient pas croire que tu couches vraiment
ma femme non malades y avons un contrat
n'est pas attention il y est
baba à l'honneur
les mcr non
il me dit que rien je sais
marie paule belle
pierre
quand il veut et chantal alice dona j'ai
le bras en été car en deuil non ils
iront d'abord je t'avais dit il
l'acteur se chiffrent en acier north j
mais qu'il a écrit
oui je n'ai
j'ai le bras
palace résonne mathieu vladimir cosma
approche non
ben non non je craque
non
moi je le dis parce que je ne peux plus
écouter c'est francis la santé mais que
nikos mataly la danse à voter la loi si
j'ai quelque chose
c'est le sol mais je suis ça dort
médecin personnel très belle chanson
écrite par bernard didier
[Musique]
c'était sa valeur si
si vous soulevez le point bas là c'est
pas compliqué lionel richie bravo fait
combien méline 6 2 et au passage à la
barre mais ça donne envie de baiser
après son danser un slow la joue bien et
dans ce vivier
[Musique]
ce soir
françois michèle torr
[Applaudissements]
didier mon vieux
bénézit or le poids madame été soufflé
par là
ramallah mais il était suppléé par là
attention devil s
[Musique]
là
et voilà donc ça fait combien mais
gentil jeu avec niort la naf dès
maintenant la chanson qui donne vraiment
envie de se suicider vous êtes prêts je
tenais là nos lames de rasoir comme ça
on est pas prêt
attention vous êtes prêt didier digard
trophée la famille rose
ce que tu as fait tes gars tu fais bas
lara fabian
c'est vraiment les chansons que si on
les connaît c'est la route la whey un
tag agnès de la bravo bravo juliette
c'est bien
ap
entend bien en 105 ans allez
je mets
pierre palmade
ce soir lio l'album s'appelle
l'heure de ruby farinas merci d'apple
bienvenue au gie le truc du style on
line à feuilles fini par s enjoy
julie depardieu et laurier du jet de
flamme bromés revers
le bouquin s'appelle en noir et maison
blanche essais publiés
j'en fais de la neige sylvie testud
alors y'a pas beaucoup les toits que ce
soir chez pauvert et des dalles
le film de rené mon sort avec sylvie
testud lambert wilson
frédéric diefenthal ça sent le 10
septembre voilà cindy jackson merci d
arreter avec des tatous diome le ventre
de l'atlantique c'est chez anne carrière
juliette arnaud arrête je pleurais
l'homme religieux dans l'eau et ses deux
copines ou rêvées glace la partie 1 506
savoir et reporter sans frontières je
vous rappelle au dénoncé l' impression à
cuba pendant sans frontières organise
une soirée le lundi 29 septembre au
théâtre du rond point des champs elysées
avec le planant catherine deneuve
sophie marceau pour tout renseignement
un mail et 16 points or voilà c'était
tout le mental
rendez vous jeudi prochain j'espère que
beigbeder sera remis sur pied merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]